Hey guys, okay, I'm doing an intro right now for SmartList and I just got back from the market, I just bought a bunch of tapioca. I got nothing except a brand new fresh out of the oven episode of SmartList for you guys and a couple of morons to help me with it. Stay tuned. Here it comes. Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart.
大家好，好吧，我現在正在為 SmartList 錄製開場白，我剛從市場回來，我剛買了一堆木薯。我除了為你們準備一集新鮮出爐的 SmartList 節目之外，什麼也沒有，還有幾個白癡來幫我。敬請期待。它來了。Smartless。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Hey, how was the golf vacation? How was your golf trip? It was good, it was really, really good. You really missed one there, Arnett. And that's okay, I was working. I was working. You were busy providing.
Less。嘿，高爾夫假期過得怎麼樣？你的高爾夫之旅怎麼樣？很好，真的非常非常好。阿奈特，你這次真的錯過了。沒關係，我在工作。我在工作。你當時忙著賺錢養家。
Oh, I thought you guys went together. I couldn't go, I had to work. I tried, I tried. I was with your wife last night, Jason. Sorry? I hung out with your wife last night. There we go. And your daughter who I love.
哦，我以為你們是一起去的。我不能去，我得工作。我試過了，我試過了。傑森，我昨晚跟你太太在一起。抱歉？我昨晚跟你太太混在一起。這就對了。還有我愛的你女兒。
Yeah, she's pretty great. So that was a 10 year old, that's Maple. The 15 year old Franny had her sweet 16 this weekend. I know, I love that. No kidding. She did. And is the boyfriend back? Were you back for it?
對，她挺棒的。那是一個10歲的小孩，那是梅珀爾。15歲的弗蘭尼這個週末剛過完她的甜蜜16歲生日。我知道，我超喜歡那個。真的假的。她真的過了。男朋友回來了嗎？你趕回來了嗎？
I came back just in time to drive to where she was having it to kick them all out and lock up. And it was great. I was ready to see things that I wasn't ready to see and I didn't see anything that I was worried about. It was very, I mean, there was like bowls of chips and Oreo cookies laid out on trays. You weren't like sweeping up vape cartridges.
我剛好趕回來，開車去她辦派對的地方，把他們全都趕出去然後鎖門。感覺很棒。我準備好看一些我不該看的東西，結果我什麼擔心的東西都沒看到。非常好，我是說，桌上擺著一碗碗的洋芋片和奧利奧餅乾。你沒有像在清理電子菸彈一樣？
Exactly. At least I didn't find any. But like just sweeping up Oreo cookies and stuff and where was the party? Was it at Sean's house? Because I'm nice. There were a lot of Cheetos and cookies and pizzas. It sounds like my 51st.
沒錯。至少我沒找到。但就像是在掃洋芋片之類的，派對是在西恩家辦的嗎？因為我很nice。那裡有好多奇多、餅乾和披薩。聽起來像我的51歲生日。
I know. Sean, what was the last big party you threw, Sean? For myself or just in general? For yourself. I don't know. Years and years and years ago. Why don't you treat yourself? Well, didn't you guys come to that, remember that poker party that I had?
我知道。西恩，你辦過最大的派對是什麼時候，西恩？為了我自己還是總體來說？為了你自己。不知道。好多好多年前。你為什麼不犒勞自己一下？好吧，你們沒來過那次，還記得我辦的那場撲克派對嗎？
I don't. I did, oh my God. Sean, that was 2004. Yeah. I'm not kidding. I know, that's what I was. It was the fall of 2004 in your backyard, I was there. I can't remember the year.
我不記得。我去了，天哪。西恩，那是2004年。對。我沒開玩笑。我知道，我也是這麼想的。那是2004年的秋天，在你的後院，我就在那裡。我不記得是哪一年了。
We used to play a lot of poker, Will. Why don't we start playing poker again? We talked about it, we've been threatening. I guess we could do it over here at my Will. Why don't we start playing poker again? We talked about it. We've been threatening. I guess we could do it over here at my house. Why don't we just do it and be fun? Hey, I texted Will yesterday if I could wear these shoes with the suit pants. Are you wearing... Now, are you wearing them on the flight, too? Yeah.
我們以前經常打撲克，威爾。我們為什麼不重新開始打撲克呢？我們討論過，一直在放話。我想我們可以在我這辦，威爾。我們為什麼不重新開始打撲克呢？我們討論過。一直在放話。我想我們可以在我家辦。我們為什麼不乾脆辦一下，一定很好玩。嘿，我昨天發簡訊問威爾，我能不能穿這雙鞋配西裝褲。你現在... 怎麼，你搭飛機也穿這樣嗎？對。
Wait, wait, wait. What do you mean flight? What do you mean suit pants? Oh, right. You're taking off today. He's going to an event. Yeah, for... Why are you wearing suit pants? And who says suit pants? Aren't they called slacks? Who says slacks? Who says fucking suit pants, bro?
等等，等等，等等。你說飛機是什麼意思？你說西裝褲是什麼意思？哦，對。你今天要出發。他要去參加一個活動。對，為了... 你為什麼要穿西裝褲？而且誰會說西裝褲？不該叫休閒褲嗎？誰會說休閒褲？誰他媽的會說西裝褲啊，兄弟？
Here we go guys, here we are. Suit pants versus slacks, we'll be right back. Let's go back to the socks. Get back up and let's question the socks. Aren't there like little faces on them? Yeah, what are you doing? What is that? They're just checkers. Are they fun?
各位，我們來了，就是這樣。西裝褲對決休閒褲，我們馬上回來。我們回到襪子上吧。再說一次，我們來質疑一下這雙襪子。上面是不是有小小的圖案？對，你在幹嘛？那是什麼？只是格紋而已。好看嗎？
They're hound's tooth. Do you like people who are like, I'm gonna wear fun socks today. And I hope that people notice my fun socks and go, oh man, you must have a real sense of humor because I just noticed your socks. It really shows that you've got a real sense of humor. You've got a lot of character.
那是千鳥格的。你是不是喜歡那種會說「我今天穿了有趣的襪子，我希望別人能注意到我的有趣襪子然後說：『噢，天哪，你一定很有幽默感，因為我剛剛注意到你的襪子。』這真的展現了你很有幽默感。你非常有個性」的人？
Wow, you've got a lot of character. Look at your socks. Where are you going, Sean? I'm going to an event tonight, an award ceremony in Chicago for theater. And is the event, the event's tonight, Sean? The event's tonight, yeah. Wait, what time do you land?
哇，你真是有個性。看看你的襪子。你要去哪裡，西恩？我今晚要參加一個活動，芝加哥的一個戲劇頒獎典禮。活動是今晚嗎，西恩？活動是今晚，對。等等，你幾點降落？
Are you nominated or are you presenting? I'm nominated in Good Night Oscar. The show is nominated in Emily Burgle, who plays my wife, is nominated in the writers nominated, Doug Wright and Lisa Peterson, who directed is nominated. Amazing. Are you not nominated? not nominated and no I am nominated Such an honor. Are you also presenting? No, what time do you get in that you're leaving? I literally land and have to go straight there. Okay. Well, this feels like poor planning
你是入圍還是頒獎？我以《晚安奧斯卡》入圍了。這齣戲入圍了，飾演我太太的艾米莉·伯格爾入圍了，編劇也入圍了，道格·賴特和擔任導演的麗莎·彼得森都入圍了。太棒了。你沒有入圍嗎？我沒入圍，不對，我入圍了。真是個榮幸。你也要擔任頒獎人嗎？沒有，你幾點到，居然現在才要走？我一落地就得直奔會場。好吧，這聽起來像是事前沒規劃好。
Do you have do you have an acceptance speech written? I mean just in case I have ideas of just who you want to thank I've you be I saw it Look at Sean showed me a copy of his acceptance speech and he actually crossed out Scotty He crossed he'd had him in and then he crossed it out. Did you guys get no fight last night? No, I want to go back to the socks for two seconds. Let's not talk about the Scotty fight No, I want to talk about the curl and Oreo at him No, I want to talk about this. Did you hurl an Oreo at him? No, no, I think the socks thing is because we don't, as guys, don't get a lot of,
你有沒有...你有沒有寫好得獎感言？我是說，萬一... 我心裡有大概想感謝的人。我看到了，你看，西恩讓我看了他得獎感言的副本，他居然把史考蒂劃掉了。他劃掉了...本來有寫他的名字，後來又把他劃掉了。你們昨沒有吵架吧？沒有，我想回到襪子上講兩秒鐘。我們別談跟史考蒂吵架的事。不，我想談談朝他扔奧利奧的事。不，我想談談這個。你朝他扔了一塊奧利奧嗎？沒有，沒有，我覺得襪子的事情是因為我們身為男人，
and as far as fashion goes, a lot of room to play with, like it's always just a suit. Opportunities for high jeans with clothes. I thought you were gonna say it's always just a hoodie. But. I do have another hoodie on. Yeah, I do like to accessorize a little bit every once in a while.
就時尚而言，沒有太多可以發揮的空間，像是永遠都只能穿西裝。衣服能有高品味的機會不多。我以為你要說永遠都只有帽T。不過。我身上確實還有一件帽T。對，我偶爾確實喜歡搭配一下配件。
I don't have the moves that Will does. Because you're not afraid of a scarf or something like that, are you, Will? Or a cravat, no. What's a cravat? Yeah, what is a cravat? Ascot, I guess, I don't know. You know, I get, I get.
我可沒有威爾那種本事。因為你不排斥圍巾之類的配件對吧，威爾？或是領結，沒有。什麼是領結？對，什麼是領結？阿斯科特領巾吧，我不知道。你知道的，我懂，我懂。
I see the way he was so like trying to have patience with us Philistines that don't know. What can I do? I mean, you know, I get roasted for it if I just, you know, I get I get roasted for it if I just you know Just for my common parlance That's why I texted you because that of three of us you probably dressed the best you really do thank you very much Thank you for saying that. Yeah, I know I really take that was coming and I did say to you. Yes I mean, I think that those shoes are okay. Yes. I said give me the context where it, and he said it's this thing, it's not a big deal,
我看他剛才對我們這群不懂時尚的鄉巴佬展現出極大的耐心。我能怎麼辦？我是說，你知道的，我會因此被吐槽，如果我只是...你知道的，我會因此被吐槽，如果我只是...僅僅因為我的日常用語。這就是為什麼我發簡訊給你，因為在我們三個之中，你可能穿得最好，你真的穿得很好。非常謝謝你。謝謝你這麼說。對，我知道這早晚會來，而且我確實對你說了。沒錯，我覺得那些鞋子還可以。對。我說，給我一個適合的場合，他說就是這個活動，沒什麼大不了的，
and it's in Chicago, and I said, then it's fine. Yeah, that's a big deal. That's all you heard with Chicago, and it's good then. Yeah, well it's in Chicago, yeah it's fine. It's fine in Chicago. So they're tennis shoes, though. I'm just kidding, all my friends in Chicago, it should be noted, love Chicago,
而且是在芝加哥，我說，那這樣就行了。對，這可是大事。你一聽到芝加哥就覺得沒問題了。對，嗯，是在芝加哥，對，這樣就行了。在芝加哥就行了。不過那是球鞋耶。開玩笑的啦，我所有在芝加哥的朋友，必須說明一下，他們都很愛芝加哥。
we had a great time in Chicago, the three of us did. We did. And we love it. But Seanny, those are tennis shoes you're wearing with a suit, or am I looking at the full outfit right now Is the hoodie part of the no no the hood is just for the airplane But what do you what is your opinion Jason about like gym shoes with a suit as opposed to like dress shoes? Stop saying gym shoes and suit pants
我們在芝加哥度過了一段美好的時光，我們三個。我們確實有。而且我們很喜歡那裡。但是西乾，你居然穿著球鞋配西裝，還是我現在看到的才是整套打扮？帽T是...不，不，帽T只是坐飛機穿的。但傑森，你對西裝搭配運動鞋而不是正裝皮鞋有什麼看法？別再說運動鞋和西裝褲了。
They're there you call those what do you call you give like rich guys Stop saying gym shoes and suit pants. I wore them on the tour. What do you call those? What do you call it? You give like rich guys a problem. Sorry, we'll be right with you, yes. Those are like adult contemporary. I call those adult contemporary shoes. I'm a rich guy with a yacht.
那些...你管那些叫什麼？你給有錢人...別再說運動鞋和西裝褲了。我在巡演時穿過。你管那叫什麼？你管那叫什麼？你給有錢人製造難題。抱歉，我們馬上回來，對。那種算是當代休閒鞋。我管那種叫當代休閒鞋。我是個有遊艇的有錢人。
Yeah, I'm a finance guy and I'm trying to be cool and so my wife got me some Tom Ford sneakers. And I'm like, hey, look, I'm hip, I don't have time to think about it. I'm worried about numbers all the time, and then I'm wearing jeans, and I'm wearing these kind of sneakers kind of thing, and it's like, hey, listen, I'm wearing this suit jacket, but then I'm jeans under the desk,
對，我是個金融男，我試著裝酷，所以我老婆幫我買了一些湯姆·福特運動鞋。然後我就想，嘿，你看，我很時髦，我沒時間去想這些。我無時無刻都在擔心數字，然後我穿著牛仔鞋，穿著這種運動鞋之類的，然後就像是，嘿，聽著，我身上穿著西裝外套，但桌子底下穿著牛仔褲，
and I've got these fucking cool sneaks. Like, okay, just fucking do it or don't. All right, let's get back to business. Why am I so mad about it? And Jason, you know, Jason gets it. You know I'm not mad, let's get back to business. Why am I so mad about it? Jason, you know, Jason gets it. You know I'm not mad. I just get worried.
然後我腳上踩著這雙他媽超酷的球鞋。好吧，要嘛就他媽的好好穿，要嘛就別穿。好了，我們言歸正傳。我為什麼要為這件事這麼生氣？傑森，你知道的，傑森懂的。你知道我沒生氣，言歸正傳。我為什麼要為這件事這麼生氣？傑森，你知道的，傑森懂的。你知道我沒生氣。我只是有點擔心。
I know you're not. I know you're not. I know you're about to get real pleased. Today we have a guest that is all things. She's an actor, she's a producer, she's a mom, a model, an Academy Award winner, a United Nations Messenger of Peace, and a friend of ours. She's been in 50 films, but is younger than all of us.
我知道你沒有。我知道你沒有。我知道你快要高興死了。今天我們請到了一位全方位的來賓。她是一位演員、製作人、母親、模特兒、奧斯卡獎得主、聯合國和平使者，也是我們的好朋友。她拍過50部電影，但卻比我們所有人都年輕。
Let's find out how she gets it all done today on Smart List, shall we gang? Please welcome the one and only Charlize Theron. Oh my gosh. Yeah, the deal. Hi Charlize. Hi guys. Hi Charlize.
今天就讓我們來看看她是怎麼搞定這一切的，好嗎，各位？請歡迎獨一無二的查莉絲·塞隆。哦，天哪。真的假的。嗨，查莉絲。嗨，各位。嗨，查莉絲。
Hi Charlize. She's got a cute haircut and a cute sweater on. Cute haircut today. I do, it's a grow out. I don't think it's a haircut. It's a grow out. What's a grow out? And it's dark, listener.
嗨，查莉絲。她剪了個可愛的髮型，穿著可愛的毛衣。今天髮型很可愛。對啊，這是留長中的過渡期。我覺得不算剪頭髮。是留長中。什麼是留長中？而且是深色髮，聽眾朋友們。
It looks real good dark. Yeah, it's super cute. Have I ever seen you dark? I think so. Or brunette. What do we call it? Whatever you want. I mean, I'm not that picky about it.
染深色看起來真好看。對啊，超級可愛。我有看過你深色髮嗎？我想有吧。或是棕髮。我們該怎麼稱呼它？隨便你怎麼叫。我是說，我對這個不太挑剔。
She just put it right back into your court She's got a sweater on that I think I wore in 84 she wears it real well, thank you those back Yes, what about socks Charlize? Are you a socks? Let me see here she goes No socks, no shoes. But you got a couple tats on there. No socks. Yeah.
她直接把球又踢回給你了。她穿的這件毛衣我記得我在84年穿過，她穿起來真好看。謝謝。那些背影...對，襪子呢，查莉絲？你有穿襪子嗎？讓我看看，她來了。沒穿襪子，沒穿鞋。不過你身上有幾個刺青。沒穿襪子。對。
Sean, quick eye there, you noticed, huh? Yeah. Fast, I'm fast. How many tattoos do we have today? I have two, I'm proud to say. You have a tramp stamp? That's amazing. It's right on the small of my back.
西恩，眼神真好，你注意到了對吧？對。動作快，我動作很快。我們今天身上有幾個刺青？我有兩個，我很驕傲地說。你有個下背刺青？太驚人了。就在我的下背部正中央。
It just says breathe, yeah. What does it say? Breathe. It just says breathe. Yeah. What does it say? Breathe. It just says breathe. So it's working. So it's like a PSA for whoever you're with. Sean, Will, any tattoos from you two?
上面就寫著「呼吸」，對。上面寫什麼？呼吸。就寫著「呼吸」。對。上面寫什麼？呼吸。就寫著「呼吸」。所以這很有用。所以這就像是給跟你在一起的人看的宣導廣告。西恩、威爾，你們兩個有刺青嗎？
That killed Sean. That's hysterical. Sure, Sean's laughing because it's an idea. I need tattoos. Right. No tattoos from Will, Sean? No, I've always wanted to get one. When I was young, I wanted to get one on my bicep.
西恩快笑死了。這太爆笑了。當然，西恩在笑是因為這也是個點子。我需要刺青。對。威爾、西恩，沒有刺青？沒有，我一直很想去刺一個。我年輕的時候，想在二頭肌上刺一個。
My what? My bicep. And then what happened? It went away so you had no place to put it. I wanted to get Wendell Clark. One of those when you're waving, it speaks. It's like a... I know, that's what's happening to me now.
在我的什麼？我的二頭肌。然後呢？它萎縮了，所以你沒地方刺了。我想刺溫德爾·克拉克。那種你揮手時，它會說話的刺青。就像是... 我知道，我現在也遇到這種情況了。
At 53, I don't That's what's happening to me now at 53. I don't like to show my tattoos on, because both are on my girl's names on the inside of my arm there. I don't notice how, I don't say bicep. And then when I show it to somebody when they ask, and then that little bottom part of the arm just starts to wave at them, it's not good.
在53歲這年，我... 我現在53歲，也遇到這種情況了。我不喜歡把刺青露出來，因為兩個刺青都是我女兒的名字，在手臂內側。我沒注意到，我不能說二頭肌。然後當我把刺青秀給別人看，當他們問起時，手臂下面那一小塊肉就開始跟著他們揮手，這感覺不太好。
I have my girl's middle names on my arm too. Do you? Oh, that's cute. In charcoal gray right here. But on your forearm? On my forearm, yes. Okay, so let me ask you actors with tattoos, do you have to go through makeup when you're doing a movie?
我手臂上也刺了我女兒們的中間名。真的嗎？哦，太可愛了。就在這裡，用碳灰色。但是在前臂上？在我的前臂上，是的。好吧，那我請問你們這些有刺青的演員，你們拍電影時是不是得去化妝？
Like is it a pain in the ass to get... Yeah, you gotta get it covered up. I did for the first year of Ozark and then I said enough. Let's just say my guys got tattoos. Who cares? What about you, Charlize? I did this in charcoal gray, so it doesn't really photograph, it's super light.
這是不是很麻煩，要把... 對，你得把它們遮蓋掉。我拍《黑錢勝府》的第一年是這樣，後來我說夠了。乾脆就說我這個角色有刺青。誰在乎？你呢，查莉絲？我是用碳灰色刺的，所以拍出來不是很明顯，顏色超淡。
And so it doesn't, you don't really, you don't pick it up. And I have found, as a producer, that when they're light like this, it's easy to take them out in the DI. You don't have to put a ton of makeup. It's almost easier to just leave it alone if it's a light tattoo. And to just take it out of the D.I.
所以它不會...你基本上拍不出來。而且身為製作人，我發現當刺青顏色這麼淡時，在數位中間片（DI）後製階段很容易把它們去掉。你不需要化厚厚一層妝。如果是淡淡的刺青，乾脆不管它，然後在後製中去掉，反而還比較簡單。
But I think it started with Mike Tyson in Hangover 3, right? Where you have to get the approval or the sign-off of the person who does the tattoo. Or they can sue you later for showing a painting that you haven't bought the license for or something like that. Really? It's like playing a song. You gotta pay for it. It's kind of absurd.
但我覺得這是從《醉後大丈夫3》裡的麥克·泰森開始的對吧？你必須獲得那個刺青原作者的批准或簽字同意。否則他們日後可以控告你展示了你沒買版權的畫作或諸如此類的東西。真的嗎？就像播放一首歌一樣。你得付版權費。這有點荒謬。
Remember when shit was free? Yeah. Just remember when people didn't stress about shit that was stupid? I do. Oh, I didn't know that we're all drinking at the same time. Sorry gang. All right.
還記得以前很多東西都是免費的嗎？對。只要記得以前大家不會為什麼蠢事感到壓力就好。我記得。哦，我不知道我們是在同一時間喝酒的。抱歉啦，各位。好吧。
It's nice to see you guys, by the way. It's been a while. You too. It's been a long time, yeah. It's been many, many years. Many years. I saw you. Remember when she was. It's been many, many years. Many years. I saw you. Remember when she was on Arrested Development, Sean? What was your favorite scene?
順便說一句，很高興見到你們。好久不見了。你們也是。好久不見了，對。已經很多很多年了。很多年了。我見過你。還記得她...已經很多很多年了。很多年了。我見過你。還記得她演《發展受阻》的時候嗎，西恩？你最喜歡哪一幕？
Sean, remember when she was on Arrested Development? What was your favorite scene? Oh my God, it's one of my favorite episodes. When she came in and she... He's never seen Arrested, Charlize. It's a point of contention. She played a character named Rita. Rita.
西恩，還記得她演《發展受阻》的時候嗎？你最喜歡哪一幕？哦，天哪，那是我就最喜歡的其中一集。當她走進來，然後她... 查莉絲，他從來沒看過《發展受阻》。這成了一個爭議點。她飾演一個叫麗塔的角色。麗塔。
Who was... Was she... Charlize, were you, I bet you don't even remember either. You were a spy? I, yeah. Or we thought you were a spy. We thought I was a spy, yes.
她是...查莉絲，你是...我敢說你大概也不記得了。你是一個間諜？我，對。或者我們以為你是個間諜。我們以為我是個間諜，沒錯。
Because I had a very interesting British accent. I sounded very smart. Did you have a, growing up in South Africa, did you have an accent as a kid and got rid of it, or what happened? Oh, yeah, no, I mean I didn't speak English and really until I was like 19. I really I grew up in an area Yes, I grew up in an area. That's right. That's right That's fucking terrible
因為我有一口非常有趣的英國腔。我聽起來很聰明。你在南非長大時，小時候有口音 後來把它改掉了嗎，還是發生了什麼事？哦，對，沒有啦，就是我差不多19歲之前都不會說英語。我真的...我在一個...對，我在一個...沒錯，沒錯。這他媽的太糟糕了。
Come on, come on I know it's a very difficult accent to do in South Africa. Very, very difficult. Anyway, yeah, I didn't speak it, so I had it as a second language, but nobody in my neighborhood spoke English. But I went to ballet and there was the Royal Academy of London, and so we had these teachers from London and they couldn't speak. That was the only English I ever really heard was these two Brits yelling at us.
拜託，拜託。我知道要在南非練這種口音非常困難。非常、非常困難。不管怎樣，對，我以前不會說英語，所以英語對我來說是第二語言，但我的鄰居沒有人說英語。不過我去學芭蕾舞，那裡有倫敦皇家舞蹈學院，所以我們有一些來自倫敦的老師，他們不會說... 我聽過唯一的英語，真的就是這兩個英國人對著我們大吼大叫。
And I would do exams not even knowing I was doing exams because I didn't understand what they were saying. So when I came here at 19, it was really kind of like learning the language, and that's why it was easy for me to drop the accent because I was really learning English from scratch. I think English-speaking South Africans have a harder time Because it's an ingrained accent that they're trying to break. I didn't have that So Africans is a completely different language. It's not it's not it's not a
我甚至不知道自己在參加考試就去考了，因為我聽不懂他們在說什麼。所以當我19歲來到這裡時，真的就像是在重新學一門語言，這也是為什麼我很容易就能擺脫口音，因為我真的是從零開始學英語的。我覺得英語系的南非人要改掉口音比較難，因為那是他們試圖打破的根深蒂固的口音。我沒有那種問題。南非荷蘭語完全是另一種語言。它不是...不是...不是...
Yeah, oh, it's a very bad sense. Yeah, this is new information for you Wow, it is a combination about 44 people still speaking it. It's definitely a dying language. It's not a very helpful language. Do we know what it is a combination of? Yeah, Dutch. I mean, yeah, so we at pretty much all of Europe try to come in and take over.
對，哦，這是一個非常糟糕的觀念。對，這對你們來說是新資訊。哇，這結合了...大約還有44個人在說這種語言。這絕對是一個正在消亡的語言。這不是一個很有幫助的語言。我們知道這是什麼語言的結合嗎？對，荷蘭語。我是說，對，所以差不多全歐洲都試圖來這裡接管。
So, but the Dutch language is predominantly what it's based on. And then there's some German in there, and then we've bastardized it. So if I, I understand Dutch, but when I speak Afrikaans, a Dutch person will be like very hoity-toity about it, and they'll be like, I don't know what you're saying. Because we've kind of bastardized it.
所以，但荷蘭語基本上是它的基礎。然後裡面有一些德語，然後我們把它給混雜篡改了。所以如果我...我聽得懂荷蘭語，但當我說南非荷蘭語時，荷蘭人會表現得非常自命不凡，他們會說：「我聽不懂你在說什麼。」因為我們有點把它給改得面目全非了。
We flattened it out a little bit. They might even say that's a terrible, terrible accent, like you said to me. Wait, I'm an idiot. Did you ever play a part where you had to do a South African accent? I did, yeah. You did, yeah.
我們把它念得比較平淡一點。他們甚至可能會說：「這是一個糟糕透頂的口音」，就像你對我說的那樣。等等，我是個白痴。你有演過需要講南非口音的角色嗎？我有，對。你有，對。
Probably super famous movie, and I'm a dumb dumb. No, it's not actually. It's a, yeah, it was a film called The Last Face. Okay, because I could talk to you for nine hours about Alien Prometheus right now, because it's one of my favorite movies. I love doing it. Thank you, Scotty.
可能是超級知名的電影，而我卻是個大笨蛋。不，其實不是。那是...對，那是一部叫《最後的面孔》的電影。好吧，因為我現在可以跟你聊九小時的《異形：普羅米修斯》，因為這是我最喜歡的電影之一。我超愛演那部片的。謝謝你，史考蒂。
Scotty's creeping in in the background for some movies. It did look like the door was open. Oh, it's the dog. It's the dog. If it was Scotty on all fours just coming to listen. Aww. All right. Well, okay.
史考蒂又在背景鬼鬼祟祟地晃來晃去想看電影。看起來門確實是開著的。哦，那是狗。那是狗。如果是史考蒂用四隻腳爬過來偷聽。噢。好吧。好吧。
So then you said you came here at 19. Charlize, let's go back. So we're in South Africa. We decide to go to, now ballet was not first, was it modeling in Milan? Well, I started dancing when I was really young and then I went to an art school for dance and that's really what I wanted to do with my life.
所以你剛才說你19歲來到這裡。查莉絲，我們回頭談談。所以我們在南非。我們決定去... ballet不是一開始就有的吧？是去米蘭當模特兒嗎？嗯，我真的很小的時候就開始跳舞，然後我去了一所藝術學校學舞蹈，那確實是我一生想做的事。
I just, I fell in love with dance and, I I mean really what I fell in love with was storytelling, but I didn't know it then. Because technically I was never the strongest dancer, but when I was Swan Lake, I would fucking die on the stage. And so I always got work because I could perform. Stop nodding, Sean. Oh, okay, sorry. I mean, he's eagerly nodding.
我只是...我愛上了舞蹈，我的意思是，我真正愛上的是說故事，但我當時不知道。因為嚴格來說，我從來不是最強的舞者，但當我跳《天鵝湖》時，我他媽的會在舞台上拼死演出。所以我總是能接到工作，因為我很會表演。別點頭了，西恩。哦，好吧，抱歉。我是說，他正迫不及待地猛點頭呢。
But yeah, that's what I wanted to do with my life until I kind of couldn't and had to kind of rethink my life and my mom was the one that pointed out that it was maybe more the storytelling aspect of it that I loved than the dance. And so she was the one that kind of put it together that maybe I should go and try acting, which was like the most stupid, ignorant,
但對，這就是我這一生想做的事，直到我做不下去，不得不重新思考我的人生，我媽媽是那個指出比起舞蹈，我可能更熱愛其中的說故事層面的人。所以是她把這些點連結起來，覺得或許我應該去嘗試演戲，這簡直是最愚蠢、最無知的...
like we knew nothing. Nothing about how you would even go about to be an actor. So how did you? A one-way ticket to Hollywood. She literally bought me a one-way ticket to Los Angeles. Wow, no way. And I got off the plane and I had nowhere to stay. I mean, I just had no plan. I stayed at the farmer's daughter because the cab drove me over.
就像我們對此一無所知。對於如何成為一名演員完全沒有概念。那你到底是怎麼做到的？一張去好萊塢的單程票。她 literalmente 買了一張去洛杉磯的單程票給我。哇，真的假的。我下飛機時根本沒地方住。我的意思是，我完全沒有計畫。我住在「農夫之女汽車旅館」，因為計程車把我載到那裡。
On Fairfax. Yeah, and now it's cute. Back then it was like a by the hour. I bought a bottle of bleach right across from the Vaughn's and started cleaning that bathroom and I stayed there for like six months. I stayed there for an hour once. Hey, oh.
在費爾法克斯大道上。對，現在那裡很可愛。當時那裡簡直是按時計費的。我在沃恩超市對面買了一瓶漂白水，開始打掃那個浴室，我在那裡住了大約六個月。我有一次在那裡住過一個小時。嘿，哦。
Now did you take acting classes right away? Not right away. I had a very strange experience where, kind of like the Lana Turner, soda fountain story where I was at a bank trying to cash a check from New York, which was an out of state check, and I couldn't cash it, and this guy was trying to help me cash it,
那你馬上就去上表演課了嗎？沒有馬上。我有一段非常奇怪的經歷，有點像拉娜·特納在蘇打噴泉的故事，當時我在銀行試著兌現一張來自紐約的支票，那是一張外州支票，我兌現不了，這個人試著幫我兌現，
and he ended up being a manager. And he signed me on, which is just weird, because I could barely speak English, and that tells you everything about how we find our actors these days. But anyway, he told me about an acting class, and I started going there, like once, what I could afford, which was like once a week at that time.
結果他竟然是一位經紀人。他就跟我簽約了，這真的很詭異，因為我幾乎不會說英語，這說明了我們現在是怎麼尋找演員的一切。不過不管怎樣，他告訴我有一個表演課，我開始去上課，一次...在我有能力負擔的時候，當時大概是一週一次。
And that was helpful, because I knew nothing about acting. I knew nothing. I didn't even know who actors were. Like I loved Tom Hanks movies without knowing his name was Tom Hanks. Well God, there's so much in there. How long was he your manager, this guy? He was my manager for about four years. Wow, you're so lucky you found the actual manager
這對我很有幫助，因為我對表演一無所知。我什麼都不懂。我甚至不知道演員是誰。就像我超愛湯姆·漢克斯的電影，卻根本不知道他的名字叫湯姆·漢克斯。天哪，裡面有太多東西了。這個人當你經紀人多久？他當了我大約四年的經紀人。哇，你太幸運了，居然能找到真正的經紀人，
that says, hey young lady, I'm a manager. Like you found a real one. Instead of like, my office is in my van. Yeah, everybody said that. They were like, this guy, this is what happens to everybody, like you're gonna end up in a ditch. And then somebody actually knew him, who was in my car. His card was in my car for like months
會說：「嘿，年輕小姐，我是一位經紀人。」就像你找到了個靠譜的。而不是像那種「我的辦公室在我的廂型車裡」的人。對，每個人都這麼說。他們就說：「這傢伙...這就是每個人都會遇到的情況，你最後會橫死路邊。」然後剛好有人認識他，那個人就在我的車上。他的名片在我的車裡放了好幾個月，
and they said, yeah, he represents John Hurt. And I was like, well, that's a real actor. Okay, so I called him. Wow. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Now, when you, so when you started going to these acting classes
然後他們說：「對，他代理約翰·赫特。」我就想：「嗯，那可是個真正的演員。」好吧，所以我打給了他。哇。我們馬上回來。現在回到節目中。那麼，當你...當你開始去上這些表演課，
and you didn't really know what acting was, you said, was your experience with it and it's starting to become comfortable to you did you have the sense like oh well they just kind of have a name for all these things that I'm just kind of naturally doing anyway in other words did you find a very natural approach to acting or were you studying sort of like the technique and like going kind of dot-to to dot about how to act or did it just kind of come naturally to you because you're so good at it and you never really see you acting.
而且你其實並不知道表演是什麼，你說，你對它的體驗以及開始感到自在時，你當時有沒有這種感覺：哦，原來大家只是給這些我本來就自然而然在做的事情起了個名字？換句話說，你找到了一種非常自然的表演方法，還是在研讀某種技巧，像按圖索驥一樣去學習怎麼演戲？還是它就只是自然而然地發生，因為你本來就很擅長，而且大家從來沒看過你在「演戲」？
It seems like it's very natural for you. Oh, thanks, Jason. I think it was a natural ability. It's easy for me to escape. Like I think I used it in my childhood. It was a way for me to survive. And it's where I've always found solace. And I think of it as this amazing opportunity
看起來你演得非常自然。哦，謝謝你，傑森。我覺得這是一種天賦。對我來說逃避現實很輕鬆。我想我小時候就經常這樣。這是我生存的一種方式。這也是我一直尋找慰藉的地方。我覺得這是一個絕佳的機會，
that I get to go and do whatever it is at that time, material-wise, that I just get to dive into completely. And I love that aspect of it, and that is easy for me. But I didn't know how to break a script down, and I didn't even know how to read a script, and I didn't know how to break a script down, and I didn't even know how to read a script, and I didn't know about an arc necessarily. So all of that stuff I had to learn, and that's what this class was really helpful for.
我可以去參與並全心投入當時劇本中的任何題材。我熱愛這方面的特質，這對我來說輕而易舉。但我當時不知道怎麼拆解劇本，我甚至不知道怎麼讀劇本，我不知道怎麼拆解劇本，我甚至不知道怎麼讀劇本，我也不太懂什麼是劇情弧線。所以所有這些東西我都必須學習，這也是這個表演課真正有幫助的地方。
Because they didn't just have actors, they had writers, they had directors. So I was around people, and I could see kind of, you know, from a little bit higher in the ground, not so. Did you have an early experience with an actor or a director on a job where you saw them with the actor maybe breaking down their script or a director sort of, did anybody,
因為他們不只有演員，還有編劇、導演。所以我身邊圍繞著這些人，我可以從一個稍微高一點的角度來看待事情，而不是那麼...你在早期的工作中有沒有跟某個演員或導演有過這樣的經驗，你看到他們和演員一起拆解劇本，或者導演...有沒有任何人，
was anybody a real helpful influence for you like actually at work as opposed to in a in a class? Oh yeah I mean I think yes this class was helpful but really ultimately I became a student as I was working I mean I think that's always the best way to work and I look at all of my experiences early on I found great mentorship with producers and directors and writers and actors who really just took me under my wing. I'm here because of the grace of a lot of those people and kindness of a lot of those people
有沒有誰對你產生了真正有幫助的影響，是指在工作現場，而不是在課堂上？哦，對，我的意思是，是的，這個表演課很有幫助，但最終我是在工作中成為一個學生的。我的意思是，我覺得那永遠是最好的工作方式。我回顧我早期的所有經歷，我在製作人、導演、編劇和演員身上找到了很好的導師，他們真的把我庇護在羽翼之下。我能有今天，都是因為許多這樣的人的恩典和許多這樣的人的善良，
because I was so eager. And so I think they were entertained by me. Did you have a moment with one of them though where that you remember now that you kind of go back to and go that was a powerful moment, somebody that I worked with, director, writer, actor, early on. Yeah, I mean, I worked with this writer, director,
因為我當時求知若渴。所以我想他們覺得我很有趣。不過你跟他們其中一人有沒有過這樣的時刻——你現在回想起來還會記得很深刻，覺得那是一個很有力量的時刻——跟你合作過的人，無論是導演、編劇、演員，在早期的時候。對，我的意思是，我跟一個編劇兼導演合作過，
John Hertzfeld, it was my first film that I ever did, and he was very kind, you know, he was very patient. I had to do a lot of stuff with James Spader, who's lovely, but like, he's a pro, you know? He like shows up and he's ready to rock and roll. I think I was 19 at the time. There were moments where John really helped me, I think, get through a shoot that could have been tough
約翰·赫茨費爾德，這是我拍的第一部電影，他人非常好，你知道的，他很有耐心。我得跟詹姆斯·史派德一起拍很多戲，他人很好，但他可是個專業人士，對吧？他一出現就準備好要大顯身手了。我想我當時大概19歲。有些時刻，約翰真的幫了我很多，我想，幫我度過了一次可能會很艱難的拍攝，
because I was so inexperienced. So I'm grateful to him always. But then I got to work with Tom Hanks right after that and he was just fucking lovely because with him it was just all about the joy. He was just like, lean into the joy, the joy, the joy. And then I also had like, you know, counter-experiences. Like I love Taylor Hackford.
因為我太沒經驗了。所以我永遠感激他。但緊接著我又跟湯姆·漢克斯合作，他簡直他媽的太棒了，因為對他來說，一切都關於快樂。他總是說：「投入快樂，快樂，快樂。」然後我也經歷過...你知道的，相反的經驗。像是我很愛泰勒·海克福德。
I did a film called Devil's Advocate with him, with Al Pacino and Keanu Reeves and that was a really big movie for me. He loves, he really encourages Method, and so everybody, you don't really have a choice. That's just kinda like how he makes, I don't know now, but that was back then. So explain for Tracy, the non-entertainment people,
我跟他合作過一部叫《魔鬼代言人》的電影，有艾爾·帕西諾和基努·李維，對我來說那是一部非常大的電影。他喜歡...他非常鼓勵體驗派（Method），所以每個人...你其實別無選擇。這大概就是他拍電影的方式，我不知道現在怎麼樣，但那是當年的情況。所以請為崔西、為我們這些娛樂圈外的人解釋一下，
what Method is. It's basically immersing yourself in the character Explain for Tracy, the non-entertainment people, what Method is. It's basically immersing yourself in the character in the world 24-7, and so you're never ever out of it. You stay in it, you're a director, we'll call you by the character name. You're kind of immersed in it the whole time. Those people are super fun to hang out with. That's exactly it.
什麼是體驗派。基本上就是把自己完全沉浸在角色中。請為崔西、為我們這些娛樂圈外的人解釋一下，什麼是體驗派。基本上就是把自己24小時、每週7天完全沉浸在角色和世界中，所以你永遠、永遠不會跳脫出來。你一直留在角色裡，你是個導演，我們會用角色的名字叫你。你整個人都沉浸在其中。跟這種人一起混一定超好玩的。就是這樣。
So I realized on that film that that was definitely not a process that was gonna work for me. There was something so exhausting about it. My life was miserable. I wasn't happy. And then of course you worry, because you're like, well, if I don't do that,
所以我那部電影中意識到，這絕對不是適合我的表演方式。那種狀態實在太消耗心力了。我的生活變得一團糟。我不快樂。然後你當然會擔心，因為你會想：「嗯，如果我不用這種方法，
then maybe I won't be as good as the Marlon Brandos and the Monty Cliffs. So you read all these biographies. And then I did some work, non-method, and I was actually really happy with the work. And I think- You could pop in and out, yeah? For me, having the energy to be able to go
那我也許就不會像馬龍·白蘭度或蒙哥馬利·克利夫特那麼優秀。」所以你讀了所有這些傳記。後來我嘗試了一些非體驗派的表演，我其實對自己的作品感到非常滿意。而且我覺得...你可以隨時跳進跳出，對吧？對我來說，有足夠的精力能夠在黑暗的題材中走得更遠，
a lot further in darker material is way more helpful than being exhausted. When I'm exhausted, I'm a little bit, I'm just too tired. I almost don't want to go into the dark room. But I think when I, so I made it a real discipline. I think dance really helped me with this. I work and I leave it behind and I come home and I pick up my dog shit and I love my kids
這比精疲力竭要有用得多。當我精疲力竭時，我會有點...我實在太累了。我甚至不想走進那個黑暗的房間。但我覺得當我...所以我把它變成了一種真正的紀律。我覺得舞蹈對此幫了很大忙。我工作，然後把工作拋在腦后，我回家，清理我的狗大便，我愛我的孩子們，
and I make pasta and drink a beer and life is good. Well, you're so goddamn funny. I wish you'd do more comedies. I'll bet they just don't come your way, right? I mean, it's just a question of them not sending you a bunch of comedic stuff. Are you talking to Sean? Yeah.
我做義大利麵，喝杯啤酒，生活真美好。哇，你他媽的太幽默了。我真希望你多演點喜劇。我敢說只是劇本沒找上你，對吧？我的意思是，這只是一個他們沒有送一堆喜劇劇本給你的問題。你在跟西恩說話嗎？對。
Yeah, Charlize, we'll be with you in one second. What? What? Like, you know, there, it's like, well maybe you wouldn't mind being immersed in, well I guess it depends on what sort of comedic character it would be, but going method on a comedy would not be as painful,
對，查莉絲，我們馬上回來陪你。什麼？什麼？就像，你知道的，在那裡，就有點像...也許你會不介意沉浸在...嗯，我想這要看是什麼樣的喜劇角色，但是在喜劇中採用體驗派應該不會那麼痛苦吧，
I would suppose. I think comedy is, you know, it's very much like a taste thing. Like I think you love comedy because you find something funny and I think that's where I struggle sometimes. Yeah, there's certain kinds of funny. Yeah, so like for me, the reason why, you know, I had just won the Academy Award for Monster
我想是的。我覺得喜劇嘛，你知道的，這非常主觀，像是一種品味問題。我覺得你喜歡喜劇是因為你覺得某些東西好笑，而我覺得這正是我有時會掙扎的地方。對，有些特定類型的笑點。對，所以對我來說，為什麼...你知道的，我剛憑《女魔頭》贏得奧斯卡獎，
and the first job I did was working with you guys on Arrested Development because- Makes sense. To me, I just thought this is such an opportunity to work with these geniuses that I might never get again. Uh-huh, I don't buy it. The geniuses weren't available so you came and worked with us. Mitch was amazing and kind of like approaching me
我接的第一個工作就是跟你們合作《發展受阻》，因為——這說得通。對我來說，我只覺得這是一個跟這些天才合作的絕佳機會，以後可能再也沒有了。嗯哼，我才不買帳呢。天才們剛好沒空，所以你才來跟我們合作。米奇人超好，他走過來跟我說：
and saying like, do you find this funny? Like let's, if you find this funny, we can figure something out. And that's kind of the comedy that I'm, I don't want to, I don't think I can do comedy that I don't myself find funny. Like I loved working with the Point Grey guys and Seth Rogen on Long Shot.
「你覺得這個好笑嗎？我們來...如果你覺得好笑，我們可以想辦法搞定。」這大概就是我喜歡的那種喜劇，我不想...我覺得我無法去演那些連我自己都覺得不好笑的喜劇。就像我超愛跟保羅·費格團隊還有塞斯·羅根合作《選情告急》。
Like that was a movie that I really loved. I would make that movie over and over and over again because it was just hands down one of the best experiences. Jonathan Levine kind of shepherded that thing and everybody was just, I find them very funny. How great is Seth, too? He's such a good dude. Yeah, hilarious.
那是一部我真心喜愛的電影。我可以把那部電影拍上一遍又一遍又一遍，因為那毫無疑問是最好的體驗之一。強納森·萊文很好地主導了那個項目，每個人都...我覺得他們非常好笑。塞斯有多棒啊？他真的是個好人。對，超爆笑。
I remember how our minds were blown that you were coming to do the show. Remember, Will, we were just like, with what? Yeah. Charlize Theron's coming here? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Aw, that's so sweet. It was difficult.
我記得當你說要來客串時，我們的腦洞有多震撼。記得嗎，威爾，我們當時的反應就像是...跟什麼一起？查莉絲·塞隆要來這裡？對，對，對。噢，太甜了。這很不容易。
I was so nervous, I'm gonna tell you guys right now. I don't think. We were petrified. I would say that's like my top five most nervous jobs I've ever done, because people don't think we were petrified. I would say that's like my top five most nervous jobs I've ever done because people don't think of me as funny. So there's this version of like oh Here comes the dramatic, you know, but what was great that's gonna like come and fuck our show up Yeah, you were just playing this great character, you know, like it wasn't funny to her, you know That was that was that brand of humor. Yeah, and that's I think that's the humor that I like
我當時緊張得要命，我現在就告訴你們。我不覺得。我們都嚇壞了。我會說那是我有生以來最緊張的前五個工作之一，因為大家不覺得我們嚇壞了。我會說那是我有生以來最緊張的前五個工作之一，因為大家不覺得我擅長搞笑。所以就會有這種版本：「哦，這個劇情演員要來了，」
But I do feel pressure some like not pressure, but you guys are so good So I look at you guys, and I go I When I watched you two and that whole cast I have to say it's effortless But I also know you guys have been on the show for a while, and you get into a thing It's like there's nothing worse than being the new kid on the show. Like when you show up and it's like... Right, but hopefully you saw how quickly we were all morons and it was just this big dumb family. We were idiots.
你知道的，就像「她要來把我們的節目搞砸了」。對，你當時只是在演這個很棒的角色，你知道的，對她來說這不好笑，你知道的，那種就是那種幽默風格。對，而我覺得那就是我喜歡的幽默。但我的確感受到一些壓力，某種...不是壓力，而是你們實在太厲害了。所以我看著你們，我就覺得...當我看到你們兩個還有整個演員陣容時，我必須說，這看起來毫不費力。但我同時也知道你們已經在這個節目待了一陣子了，你們已經進入狀況了。沒有什麼比當節目裡的新人更糟糕的了。就像你一出現，然後...沒錯，但希望你有看到我們大家是多麼快就原形畢露，變成一個超大又搞笑的笨蛋家族。我們都是白癡。
No, I found you guys very impressive actually. Very impressive. We were very... I remember just being like, what? I'm just feeling so... I have a question though. You turned into George Michael. I really did.
不，其實我覺得你們非常令人印象深刻。非常印象深刻。我們非常...我記得當時心想：什麼？我感覺自己好...不過我有個問題。你變成了喬治·麥可。我真的變成了。
I did. It was embarrassing. But what's kind of mind blowing to me just hearing your story about coming here at 19 and not speaking English, you just kind of, it's kind of mind blowing that you jumped into these films like with these huge successful people right away where most actor stories are like, I did this commercial and I tried to get a TV show,
我真的變了。真丟臉。但聽到你19歲來到這裡而且不會說英語的故事，對我來說真的有點震撼，你竟然直接就接演了這些電影，而且立刻就能跟這些超大牌的成功人士合作，而大多數演員的故事都是：「我拍了這個商業廣告，我試著爭取一個電視劇演出，
I couldn't do that. You know, your journey was so quick and fast. I did that. I just skipped over it. I did like Ross Dress for Less commercials. Oh, okay, okay. And by that I mean I was like an extra in the back, you know, like not featured.
但我做不到。」你知道的，你的演藝之路進展得太快了。我有經歷過那些啊。我只是跳過去了。我有拍過羅斯服飾店（Ross Dress for Less）的商業廣告。哦，好吧，好吧。我的意思是，我只是背景裡的臨時演員，你知道的，不是那種特寫鏡頭。
But no, trust me, I was an extra in Children of the Corn 3. Oh, okay. No, it was definitely not like an extra in Children of the Corn 3. Oh, okay. I... No, it was definitely not like, oh, here you go, be an actor. And what about roommates? Did you have to find other actor room? Like, how was the living situation growing up?
但真的，相信我，我曾在《玉米田的小孩3》裡演過臨時演員。哦，好吧。不，絕對不是那種「哦，來吧，去當個演員」的順利。室友呢？你必須找其他演員當室友嗎？像你那時的居住環境是怎麼樣的？
Yeah, yeah, I mean, I lived in a loft with two other girls right next to the Big Five down in San Vicente. Oh, sure. And lived there for years, and it was like a one bedroom loft. It was just a room and a bed coming out of the wall. And three of us lived there for years.
對，對，我的意思是，我和另外兩個女孩住在聖維森特大五超市旁邊的一個閣樓裡。哦，當然。在那裡住了好多年，那只是一個一房的閣樓。那只是一個房間，床是從牆壁拉出來的。我們三個人在那裡住了好多年。
The bathroom was literally right next to the kitchen. And I just, I would look at that toilet from the kitchen sink and I just said to myself, let this be the motivation, let this be the motivation motivation you need to live somewhere where our toilet is right now nice to the kitchen That was like that was a huge motivation You still talk to you and Scotty put a toilet in the kitchen just just to cut down the commute To cut down the commute you can only put so much sloppy Joe in your face before you know You just can't make it they did the math they did the only put so much sloppy Joe in your face before you just can't make it to the toilet.
浴室離廚房 literalmente 只有幾步之遙。我每次從廚房水槽看那個馬桶，心裡就對自己說：讓這成為動力吧，讓這成為你需要的動力，去住一個馬桶離廚房稍微遠一點的地方。那簡直是...那是一個巨大的動力。你還跟...你跟史考蒂在廚房裡裝了一個馬桶，單純只是為了縮短通勤時間。
They did the math on how much time they waste going back and forth. They sat down, they had a meeting with their business manager. Oh, the truth is so funny sometimes. Charlize is still trying to catch a breath. We'll wait. We could trim it all out.
為了縮短通勤時間。你嘴裡只能塞那麼多邋遢喬三明治，然後你就知道...你真的來不及上廁所了。他們算過帳了，他們計算了他們來回奔波浪費了多少時間。他們坐下來，跟他們的商業經紀人開了個會。哦，有些真相有時真的太好笑了。查莉絲還在喘口氣。我們等一下。我們可以把這段全部剪掉。
By the way, I've made these guys sloppy joes a couple times now. So maybe that's why. Well, I've heard about your Swedish fish and I've listened you guys sloppy joes a couple times now. So maybe that's why. Well I've heard about your Swedish fish. Yeah, I listen to the show. The plug that a Swedish fish and a piece of sloppy joe can make. So Charlize, the cushy shooting situation there at 20th Century Fox when we were doing Arrested is nothing compared
顺便说一句，这阵子我给这几个家伙做了好几次滑头鬼肉酱三明治。所以也许这就是原因。好吧，我听说过你的瑞典鱼糖，而且我听你们……这阵子我给这几个家伙做了好几次滑头鬼肉酱三明治。所以也许这就是原因。好吧，我听说过你的瑞典鱼糖。对，我听这个节目。瑞典鱼糖和一块滑头鬼肉酱三明治能擦出那样的火花。所以查理兹，我们在拍《发展受阻》时，在二十世纪福斯那种安逸的片场环境，跟
to the grueling location of, say, a Mad Max, right? I mean, walk us through, was it as tough as it looked out there doing Mad Max out in the middle of an Australian desert? Oh yeah, I love that movie. Or was there something really cush just behind camera? No, we shot it in Namibia, actually. We were originally gonna shoot it in Australia, and then. Ask him where Namibia is. We were originally going to shoot it in Australia.
比如《疯狂的麦克斯》那种折磨人的外景比起来根本不算什么，对吧？我的意思是，跟我们说说，在澳大利亚沙漠中间拍《疯狂的麦克斯》，是不是像看上去那么辛苦？哦，对，我很喜欢那部电影。还是说镜头后面其实有什么非常安逸的事？不，其实我们是在纳米比亚拍的。我们原本打算在澳大利亚拍，然后……问问他纳米比亚在哪里。我们原本打算在澳大利亚拍的。
Ask him where Namibia is. Just ask him what side of Africa it's on. Do you know where Namibia is? That's over there on the left side. If you're looking at it from the north. Oh, it was a 50-50 chance. Yeah, we'll see the way I confuse you with the left and the north. It's a beautiful place, Jason.
问问他纳米比亚在哪里。就问他在非洲的哪一边。你知道纳米比亚在哪里吗？就在左边那边。如果你从北边看的话。哦，这有百分之五十的几率猜对。对，你看我把左边和北边搞混了。那是个美丽的地方，杰森。
Looks insane. Yeah, It's a beautiful place, Jason. Looks insane. Yeah, it's really beautiful. It's where, it's the only place where lions and whales meet. Like you'll see lions walk on the beach and eat, discarded whales or. No way. Yeah, it's really, it's a magical place. There's places called Skeleton Coast
看起来疯狂极了。对，那是个美丽的地方，杰森。看起来疯狂极了。对，真的很美。那是……那是狮子和鲸鱼唯一会相遇的地方。你会看到狮子走到海滩上去吃被丢弃的鲸鱼，或者……不会吧。对，真的，那是个神奇的地方。有个地方叫骷髅海岸，
and it's pretty magical. I like that. It has like dunes, There's places called Skeleton Coast. It's pretty magical. I like that. It has dunes. It's just like hundreds of miles of dunes. The desert is unbelievable. We went there because there was a flood. There was a rain monsoon that hit Australia right before, as we were in pre-production, and the whole red desert in Australia
而且非常神奇。我喜欢那样。那里有沙丘……有个地方叫骷髅海岸。非常神奇。我喜欢那样。那里有沙丘。简直就是几百英里的沙丘。那里的沙漠简直不可思议。我们去那里是因为发洪水了。澳大利亚在我们刚准备进入前期制作的时候，突然遭遇了一场暴雨季，结果澳大利亚的整片红色沙漠
just ended up being wild flowers, so not very. How long of a shoot was that, like how many months? Oh, I just wanna, listen to this. So we had 140 cars that were made in Australia, and they had to ship. They put them all on a boat and drove them on the water. What is that? Oh my God.
最后全都变成野花了，所以……没怎么拍。那是拍了多久，拍了几个月？哦，我只是想……听听这个。我们在澳大利亚造了140辆车，然后必须把它们运走。他们把所有车都装上船，从水上开过去。那是什么？噢天哪！
Sails? Sailed them on the water all the way to Namibia. Anyway, what were you asking, Sean? I was just saying, the reason why I didn't know how long it is, it's like you have to gear up mentally to be out of your house and your comfort zone because when I hear about these year-long shoots, I was like, it so uproots your life.
帆船？用船从水上一路运到纳米比亚。不管怎样，肖恩，你刚才问什么来着？我只是想说，我不知道要拍多久的原因是，你必须在心理上做好准备，离开你的家和舒适区，因为当我听说这种为期一年的拍摄时，我想，这太彻底颠覆你的生活了。
Obviously, we're all doing what we love to do, but how do you cope with that, with the uprooting? Go ahead Jason, you got a thought? I just tried to think about what would the list look like in order of heartbreak of the things you would be missing, Sean, from home if you hadn't been shooting in Namibia? Like what would be number one? You'd be like, gosh, I just don't know
显然，我们都在做自己热爱的事，但你如何应对这种生活的颠覆呢？说吧，杰森，你有什么想法？我只是在想，如果把你在纳米比亚拍戏期间最想念的家里的东西按心碎程度排个序，肖恩，你的清单会是什么样的？比如第一名会是什么？你可能会觉得，天哪，我真不知道
when I'd get my next. Well, it's my bed. My bed is like, you know, for the sleep. Like you want to sleep in your own bed and you want your own couch. Your bed with your fan. And what do you like when you sleep? You need a fan running and what else?
什么时候才能吃到下一个……好吧，是我的床。我的床就是那种，你知道的，用来睡觉的。就像你想睡在自己的床上，你还想要自己的沙发。带有电风扇的床。你睡觉的时候喜欢什么？你需要开着风扇，还有别的吗？
I need a fan, I need a pillow between my legs. I need two, like a hard and a soft pillow on the thing. Like, you know, there's a whole. And a bowl full of three Musketeer Minis with the enormous roof. That's right. Well, I gotta wake up in the morning. Like, you know, there's a whole... And a bowl full of three Musketeer minis. Well, I got to wake up in the morning. It gets me going.
我需要风扇，我需要在两腿之间夹个枕头。我需要两个，一个硬枕头和一个软枕头放在那上面。就像，你知道的，有一整套……还要有一碗装满三剑客迷你巧克力豆的碗，上面盖着巨大的盖子。没错。好吧，我早上得醒来。就像，你知道的，有一整套……还要有一碗装满三剑客迷你巧克力豆的碗。好吧，我早上得醒来。这能让我振作起来。
It's got to be within reach at any... It can't be a king-size... We're not going to get into Sean's rider right now. The point is... But the point is like you have your... But it is hard going away from... Yeah, leaving times. Yeah, it's really hard.
它必须随时触手可及……不能是特大号的……我们现在先不讨论肖恩的演出合同要求。重点是……但重点是，你得有你的……但离开确实很难……是的，离开的时候。是的，这真的很难。
I had my first kid. She was literally, I think six weeks old, and I got on a plane with her as a baby, I was a new mom, and I was, I mean I know Namibia a little bit, because most of my family is from Namibia. Namibia used to be part of South Africa, and then in the 90s it became independent.
我有我的第一个孩子。她字面意思上，我想只有六周大，我作为一个新手妈妈，抱着她坐上了飞机，而且我……我的意思是，我对纳米比亚有一点了解，因为我的大部分家人都来自纳米比亚。纳米比亚曾经是南非的一部分，然后在90年代独立了。
So Namibia was kind of familiar to me, but not that familiar, but I also, I mean, I was, it was crazy. And Jason, don't get me started, because I know, I know what has to be done for you to go away. Yeah, I would have passed. I can back you on that.
所以纳米比亚对我来说有点熟悉，但也没有那么熟悉，不过我也……我的意思是，这太疯狂了。杰森，别让我打开话匣子，因为我知道，我知道要让你出远门得付出什么。对，我本来会拒绝的。我可以为你作证。
I've been a part of it. It's fucking pathetic. Wait, no! Jason, you can't, Jason can't even move to the valley. No. Who are you fucking kidding? Trust me, we had to shoot in the valley a couple of times and it was rough, it was rough for him.
我经历过。这他妈太可悲了。等等，不！杰森，你不能，杰森连山谷区都搬不去。不。你他妈在跟谁开玩笑？相信我，我们有好几次不得不在山谷区拍戏，那对他来说太难了，太难了。
That is a word. But it was definitely long and it was the same scenery every single day, it wasn't as long as, it went way longer than we thought. So do you have to like mentally prepare like, okay, I'm gonna be gone for this long, I need a bath. This is how it has to go, whatever's in my room. And just so you can make it home,
这倒是个词。但拍摄时间确实很长，而且每天都是同样的风景，也没有那么长，它比我们想象的时间要长得多。所以你必须在心理上做好准备，比如，好吧，我要离开这么久，我需要洗个澡。事情就得这样，房间里有什么就用什么。只要能让你撑到回家，
because it's gonna be your home. I don't need a lot. I just, I think for me it was important just to know that I was safe, because safety is a bit of an issue there. Yeah. And I had a new baby, and that became the biggest issue.
因为那里将成为你的家。我不需要太多东西。我只是觉得，对我来说，最重要的是知道自己是安全的，因为安全在那里是个有点严重的问题。对。而且我当时有一个刚出生的宝宝，这就成了最大问题。
You know, it was just me and Jackson in the house, and I got broken in, like, you know, three in the morning, like five times. That was really scary. Over there. What do you mean? Broken into, while you're sleeping? Yeah, you can hear, like, I woke.
你知道的，房子里只有我和杰克逊，然后我遭遇了入室盗窃，像……你知道的，凌晨三点，大概发生了五次。那真的很吓人。就在那边。你什么意思？睡觉的时候被入室盗窃？对，你能听到，比如，我醒来……
Where were you staying, in like a tent? No, I was staying at this really nice house. Like, they have all these beautiful coastal homes right on the water and they're gorgeous. I mean, it puts Malibu to shame. But unfortunately, you're bringing in a big production, there's money, and you're dealing with people who are living way below poverty.
你当时住在哪儿，帐篷里吗？不，我住在一栋非常漂亮的房子里。就像，水边有许多漂亮的沿海住宅，美极了。我的意思是，那把马里布比得黯然失色。但不幸的是，当你带去一个大型剧组，那里的资金流动很大，而你又要跟生活在赤贫线以下的人打交道。
And so it's just, it's a recipe for disaster. So that part of it was my biggest concern. And the people that you would ostensibly hire for security would be... They were kind of part of it. ... would be local. Yeah, they were kind of part of the problem. Yeah, I ended up feeling really safe because if you know the movie, the war boys, the majority of the war boys were actually real military, Australian military that George brought out.
所以这简直是灾难的温床。所以这部分是我最担心的。而你表面上雇来负责安保的人会是……他们其实也是其中一部分。……会是当地人。对，他们其实也是问题的一部分。对，我最后感到非常安全，因为如果你知道这部电影里的“战争男孩”，大多数“战争男孩”其实都是乔治带去的真正的澳大利亚军人。
And so they... Not to be confused with hot cops, Will. Got it, got it, got it, sorry. But I would text them when I would hear something, I would text them and literally like three minutes later I would see their flashlights coming in and I just kind of relied on them and they kept me safe the whole movie.
所以他们……别跟热辣警察搞混了，威尔。明白了，明白了，明白了，抱歉。但我听到什么动静时会发信息给他们，我给他们发信息，字面意思上大概三分钟后，我就会看到他们的手电筒光芒照进来，我基本上就是靠着他们，整部电影拍摄期间他们一直在保护我的安全。
Right, oh my God. And then you wake up and it's... I mean that was a very physically grueling part for you as well. And hot and dusty. Yeah. It was actually cold. Really cold. It looks hot.
对，噢天哪。然后你醒来，然后……我的意思是，那对你来说也是体力上非常折磨人的一部分。又热又多尘。其实很冷。真的很冷。看起来很热。
Yeah, it was freezing. We had a lot of cases of hypothermia, especially the young girls who only wear bandages. A lot of them got hypothermia. I was freezing just because when you don't have hair on your head, you forget. It's like a heat releaser. So it was really cold, actually. Now I'd rather freeze than sweat. So that sounds good to me.
对，冷极了。我们有很多低体温症的病例，尤其是那些只穿着绷带的年轻女孩。她们很多人都得了低体温症。我之所以觉得冷，纯粹是因为当你脑袋上没有头发时，你就会忘了一件事。头发就像一个散热器。所以其实真的很冷。现在我宁愿冻僵也不愿出汗。所以这对我听起来挺好的。
Would you have been happier if it was 110? I like it when I have to do action. I like colder better. Right. Yeah. For sure. It's harder for me to have a ton of energy to do fight scenes when it's... I just did this movie in Rome and it was one of the hottest summers. It was 115 degrees every single day.
如果当时有110华氏度（约43摄氏度），你会更高兴吗？我喜欢拍动作戏的时候。我更喜欢冷一点的天气。对。没错。毫无疑问。当天气很热时，我要用极大的精力去拍打斗戏就更难了……我刚在罗马拍了这部电影，那是有史以来最热的夏天之一。每天都有115华氏度（约46摄氏度）。
And I had to do these fight scenes out in these Roman streets. It was just like you couldn't keep fluid in your body. And were you wearing clothes and playing a character where you weren't supposed to be sweating? Like that's when the heat was dragged. Yeah, I mean after a while I'm just like, that's like the last thing I'm fucking thinking about. I'm just, the cramping.
我还得在罗马的那些街道上拍打斗戏。简直就是你身体里根本留不住水分。你当时穿着衣服，扮演一个本来不该出汗的角色吗？那才是最折磨人的时候。对，我的意思是，过了一会儿，我只想说，这绝对是我他妈脑子里想的最后一件事情。我只想说，抽筋……
Yeah, I'm like that's like the last of my, I'm like can I just be able to walk? Like your feet start cramping because you just have no fluid in your body. So yeah, I definitely prefer a little colder. So many action films. I mean, you must have been injured beyond any ability to recuperate and keep schedules going forward.
对，我就像那是我的最后底线，我就想：我能不能正常走路？因为你的脚开始抽筋，因为你体内根本没有水分了。所以，是的，我绝对更喜欢稍微冷一点的天气。拍了这么多动作片。我的意思是，你的伤势肯定已经超出了任何恢复和维持拍摄日程的能力。
I mean, are there any stories of you just saying, all right, that's it, we're down for a couple of weeks with an injury, no? I don't know if it's stupidity or if it's just a high, I have a high, maybe a high tolerance for pain, but on the first old guard, I tore the tendon off this bone on my thumb. It got stuck in a guy's, like his, yeah, and it just,
我的意思是，有没有什么故事是你直接说，好了，就这样，我们因为受伤得停工几个星期，没有吗？我不知道这是因为我蠢，还是因为我的痛阈很高，我可能对疼痛有很高的耐受力，但在拍第一部《永生守卫》时，我把大拇指的肌腱从骨头上扯断了。我的大拇指卡在一个家伙的……就像他的，对，然后
he moved and he ripped my whole thumb back. Oh my God. And I, I mean, it was really painful. And painful and I just kind of you know when you have an injury You just kind of don't use it so much and so I just didn't use it so much But I had to do like three weeks of a big action sequence on a horse Where I was riding with that hand and fighting with the right and so I was just in denial and then I came back and And had surgery it was that it was just in denial and then I came back and had surgery. It was just floating, there was nothing holding it.
他一动，就把我的整个大拇指往后撕裂了。噢天哪。而且我……我的意思是，这真的很疼。又疼，然后你懂的，当你有伤时，你就会尽量少用它，所以我确实没怎么用它。但我必须在一匹马上完成大约三周的大型动作戏，我得用那只手骑马，用右手战斗，所以我一直在自欺欺人，然后我回来后
And I just finished the second one now. I just came back like 10 days ago and I just had shoulder surgery two days ago. That's no way. Sherrys, you're not old, but you're not 15. No, I'm not, but you know, I recover really fast, and my body is in great shape. These are all just superficial injuries.
去做了手术，就是那样……我一直在自欺欺人，然后回来做了手术。它当时就是悬空的，没有任何东西支撑着。我刚完成了第二部的拍摄。我大约10天前刚回来，两天前刚做了肩膀手术。不会吧。查理兹，你可不老，但你也不是15岁了。不，我不是，但你知道的，我恢复得非常快，我的身体状况好极了。这些都只是皮外伤。
Actually, my shoulder is actually great. My knees are great. How's your stunt double doing? Huh? How's your stunt double doing? Yeah. I mean, I bet you have the same one for years. I mean, listen, she does, she does,
其实，我的肩膀状态非常好。我的膝盖也很好。你的替身演员怎么样？啊？你的替身演员怎么样？对。我的意思是，我敢打赌你多年来一直用同一个替身。我的意思是，听着，她确实……她做……
I'm not gonna do stupid hard falls down a staircase, or falling from a second. I don't do stuff like that. But she is, is she still okay? Yeah, she's fucking 24. I mean, nothing hurts a 24. What about Liam Neeson's stunt double? He must be all banged up.
我才不会去做从楼梯上摔下来或者从二楼摔下去这种蠢透了的危险跌落。我不会做那种事。但她……她现在还好吧？对，她他妈才24岁。我的意思是，24岁的人什么都不会觉得痛。连姆·尼森的替身演员呢？他肯定浑身是伤吧。
My God. That poor bastard. It's fun to do this stuff, I like it. I really love it. You need a nice sitcom. You need a nice sitcom for season two. I don't know, I think I'm not quite ready. I think maybe in another 10 years. There's something so fucking invigorating about hanging off the side of a helicopter. You kind of got injured when you put on all that weight for Sully, right?
天哪。那个可怜的家伙。做这些事很有趣，我喜欢。我真的很喜欢。你需要一部不错的情景喜剧。第二季你需要拍一部不错的情景喜剧。不知道，我觉得我还没完全准备好。我想可能再过10年吧。挂在直升机侧面有一种他妈的让人热血沸腾的感觉。你为《萨利机长》增肥的时候好像也受过伤，对吧？
I had more injuries on that movie, yes, just from gaining weight. I herniated a disc in my lower back. Wait, how'd that happen? Well, I gained like 50 pounds and then I had to wear a pregnancy belly that Jason Reitman, the director, thought would be a good idea to make the actual size, the weight of an actual... So it weighed like another 40 pounds and then he put me in a fitting and I had to put shoes on over and over
我在那部电影里受的伤最多，是的，仅仅是因为增肥。我的下背部椎间盘突出。等等，那是怎么发生的？嗯，我重了大概50磅（约22.7公斤），然后我不得不戴上一个由导演杰森·雷特曼认为应该做成实际大小、也就是真实重量的孕妇腹具……所以它又增重了大约40磅（约18.1公斤），然后我去试装，我不得不一次又一次地弯腰穿鞋，
and just, you know, from bending and putting on shoes I herniated a disc in my lower back and that's been the worst injury I've ever had. Wow. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Can I tell you something? This is a true story.
然后，你知道的，就因为弯腰穿鞋，我的下背部椎间盘突出了，那是我经历过的最严重的一次受伤。哇。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。我能告诉你一件事吗？这是一个真实的故事。
Okay. First of all, you. Well, we're gonna listen harder. Thanks for stop lying. Go ahead, John. This is a true story. I was sitting there watching, because you have this unbelievable ability
好吧。首先，你……好吧，我们要更认真地听了。谢谢你别再撒谎了。说吧，约翰。这是一个真实的故事。我当时坐在那儿看，因为你有一种不可思议的能力，
to, like we spoke about earlier, to lose yourself in every character you play. It's very rare that, you know, there's Philip Seymour Hoffman who was just like transformative, there's you who's always transformative. It's just an incredible feat. So I'm sitting there with Scotty, my husband, watching Bombshell.
就像我们之前谈到的，能让你自己融入你扮演的每一个角色中。非常罕见的是，你知道的，有菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼，他就像是脱胎换骨型的演员，还有你，你总是能脱胎换骨。这简直是一个了不起的壮举。所以我和我丈夫斯科蒂坐在那儿看《性感eng炸弹》。
I swear to God I'm not making this up. And like half hour, 40 minutes in, I'm like, where the fuck is Charlize Theron? I thought she was in this movie. And he's like, what, you idiot? That's her. And I'm like, as Megyn Kelly, I was blown away. I mean, you look like her, you sounded like her.
我发誓上帝我绝对不是在胡编。半小时、四0分钟过去了，我在想：查理兹·塞伦他妈的在哪儿？我以为她在这部电影里。然后他说：你个白痴，那就是她。我说：作为梅根·凯利，我简直惊呆了。我的意思是，你看起来像她，你听起来也像她。
What's so funny, you guys? I think it's like amazing. Fuck them, I'm enjoying this moment, Charlize. I'm just looking at your screen right now. It's just me and you. That's all I wanted to say. I don't have a question. I was just like, I'm enjoying this moment, Charlize. I'm just looking at your screen right now. It's just me and you. Thank you. That's all I wanted to say. I have a question.
你们在笑什么呢，伙计们？我觉得这太棒了。去他们的，我很享受这个时刻，查理兹。我正看着你的屏幕呢。只有我和你。我只想说这些。我没有问题。我当时就想：我很享受这个时刻，查理兹。我正看着你的屏幕呢。只有我和你。谢谢。我只想说这些。我有个问题。
I was just like, I really truly was like, I thought Charlize was in this movie. Oh, that's nice. That's her. It is pretty impressive. I mean, it was mind blowing. What about this new thing, the school for good and evil? What are you doing in that and why do you want to do it?
我当时就想，我真的是……我以为查理兹在这部电影里。哦，这太好了。那就是她。这确实挺让人印象深刻的。我的意思是，这太让人大开眼界了。这部新作品《善恶魔法学校》怎么样？你在里面演什么角色，你又为什么想拍它？
What about it? Was it Paul Feig? Because he's a good dude. Yeah, he did a couple of episodes of our Arrested Development. Yeah, he's such an amazing guy. I also just, you know, I have two young kids now, seven and 10, and they're gonna have to be like at least 52 to see any of my work.
这部作品怎么样？是保罗·费格导的吗？因为他是个好人。对，他拍过我们《发展受阻》的好几集。对，他是个太棒的人。而且我也……你知道的，我现在有两个年幼的孩子，一个七岁，一个十岁，他们至少得长到52岁才能看到我的任何作品。
So there is a level of wanting to make stuff for them because they love this world, this kind of fantasy world. And it was also, oh fuck man, it was like towards the end of our lockdown and I was going stir crazy. I was homeschooling the two of them and I obviously couldn't take a job because I didn't want to move them.
所以有一种想要为他们创作东西的愿望，因为他们热爱这个世界，这种奇幻世界。而且这也是……哦，他妈的，那是我们封锁期的尾声，我都快急疯了。我在家里给两个孩子上网课，我显然不能接工作，因为我不想让他们搬家。
You know, it just wasn't the right time to move a whole family somewhere. So it was a two week job up in Belfast. And they got me back in 14 days and my mom took the kids. And so that was nice too. But yeah, mostly I did it for them. I want, you know, there's something, I don't know, there's something about kids that no matter who you are,
你知道的，当时绝对不是把一整家子人搬到某个地方的好时机。所以那是一份在贝尔法斯特呆两周的工作。他们14天就把我接回来了，我妈妈把孩子们接过去照顾了。所以那也挺好的。但是的，我主要是为了他们才拍的。我想要，你知道的，有那么一回事，我不知道，对孩子们来说，无论你是谁，
you want to impress them. Like they're not impressed by Meg and Kelly. Like they're not impressed by me. Right, and it's also proof of like, well, this is who you are, you wanna impress them. Like they're not impressed by Meg and Kelly. Like they're not impressed by me. Right, and it's also proof of like, well this is, you know, mom is busy, but I swear I'm busy doing stuff. I swear it, like here's something you can see. It's proof.
你都想给他们留下深刻印象。就像他们对梅根·凯利不以为然一样。就像他们对我也很不以为然。对，这也是一个证明，就是：好吧，这就是你，你想给他们留下深刻印象。就像他们对梅根·凯利不以为然一样。就像他们对我也很不以为然。对，这也是一个证明，就是：好吧，你知道的，妈妈很忙，但我发誓我真的很忙，在做各种事。我发誓，这里有你可以看到的东西。这就是证明。
Yeah. Well they see the posters when we drive to the bus. They never see the movies, right? But they always see the posters, and they spend time on set and things like that, so they think they know what the movie is. And it's really funny when they're like, they see the poster and they just go,
对。嗯，我们开车去赶公交车时他们会看到海报。他们从不看电影，对吧？但他们总是能看到海报，而且他们也会去片场探班之类的，所以他们觉得自己知道那是部怎样的电影。当他们看到海报然后说：
well, I don't know if that is the movie that I saw you make. Right, right. How do you manage to do all of this work and still be such a great mom? Because I know you put an incredible time and focus to being an incredible mother. And I know that you've got incredible help from your mother, who's an incredible mother. And I know that you've got incredible help
嗯，我不知道这到底是不是我看到你拍的那部电影。对，对。你究竟是怎么做到兼顾所有这些工作，同时还能成为一个这么棒的妈妈的？因为我知道你在做一个不可思议的母亲这件事上投入了惊人的时间和专注。而且我知道你得到了你母亲的极力帮助，她是一位了不起的母亲。而且我知道你得到了……的极力帮助
from your mother who's an incredible woman. But like, as I said in the intro, 50 films. Like, it takes a few months to do a movie, especially when you're the lead like you always are. Like, the math doesn't even work out. I don't know how you've gotten all that done and still been, you know. Well, I've been producing for, you know,
来自你母亲的帮助，她是一位了不起的女性。但就像我在开场所说的那样，50部电影。我的意思是，拍一部电影需要好几个月，尤其是当你像你一样总是担任主演的时候。这个数学根本算不过来。我不知道你是怎么完成这一切，同时还能……
close to two decades now. And I think that's really helped. Just taking some agency and making my own schedule. And so I really don't make anything, like, I don't make any big movies unless I, you know, I push it into the summer where I can take my whole family. Like, we all went to Rome for four months. But, you know, I get my kids back for school. But you're right, I can't do it without my mom.
嗯，我从事制片工作已经……快有二十年了。我觉得这真的帮了大忙。那就是掌握主动权，自己制定拍摄日程。所以我基本上不拍任何大制作电影，除非……我把它推到夏天去拍，那样我就可以带上我一大家子人。比如，我们全家去罗马呆了四个月。但是，你知道的，我得让孩子们赶回去上学。不过你说得对，如果没有我妈妈，我根本做不到。
And I'm always very vocal in acknowledging that I am co-parenting with her. And so that's kind of unusual for people to hear, but that is the truth. She really is very much a co-parent. I love that. Yeah, it's amazing. I'm so lucky.
而且我一直非常直言不讳地承认，我和她是在共同抚养孩子。所以人们听到这个可能会觉得有点不寻常，但这就是事实。她确实在很大程度上扮演了共同抚养者的角色。我喜欢这样。对，这太棒了。我太幸运了。
I'm so lucky. How much of, how much, because your mom's been there obviously the whole time and And you are so close to her. How much do you talk to her about? What choices you make as a you know sort of artistically as a producer or as a as an actor Do you have a relationship like that at all? Do you go like hey? I'm thinking about doing this thing What do you think do you take do you sound stuff off of her in that way too or no? So when I started she was definitely
我太幸运了。有多少……因为你妈妈显然一直在那里，而且你跟她那么亲近。你跟她聊多少关于你作为……你知道的，作为艺术创作者、制片人或演员所做出的选择？你们之间有那种关系吗？你会不会说：嘿，我正在考虑做这件事，你觉得怎么样？你也会跟她商量这些吗，还是不会？所以自我刚出道时，她绝对
She was way more opinionated. I mean she definitely she's she's very direct Jason you've met her. Yeah, very funny. She's very direct. She's kind of she's a broad. She's very Very brassy and loud and she loves to swear. She's just very honest. So in the beginning when I started, there was a lot of wanting her approval, but she would go and see some of my movies and just be like, that's a piece of shit.
更有主见。我的意思是，她绝对……她非常直率，杰森，你见过她。对，非常搞笑。她非常直率。她有点像个……豪爽的女人。她非常率真、嗓门大，而且喜欢爆粗口。她只是非常诚实。所以刚开始我出道时，我非常渴望得到她的认可，但她去看我的一些电影时，只会说：那是一堆狗屎。
Before you've been out of the theater. Yeah, and I was like, you should come out. And you could just tell on her face, she was like, that is not good. But I appreciate it so much from her. It's kind of a relationship. I remember as a dancer too, when I was like, that is not good. But I appreciate it so much from her. It's kind of our relationship. I remember as a dancer too, when I was little, like I would have a competition or something.
在你还没走出电影院的时候。对，我就说：你应该出来再说。你从她的脸上就能看出来，她觉得：那可真不怎么样。但我真的很感激她这一点。这有点像我们的关系。我记得当我还是个小舞者的时候……像：那可真不怎么样。但我真的很感激她这一点。这有点像我们的关系。我记得当我还是个小舞者的时候，当我年纪还小的时候，我去参加比赛什么的，
She was never the parent that would sugarcoat it. She wasn't like abusive about it, but she was very honest. I knew that when she said something was good, I was like, fuck, then that was really good. You know, like I really believed that more than the negative stuff. It becomes like a real barometer for you. Exactly.
她从来都不是那种会粉饰太平的家长。她倒不是虐待式的那种，但她非常诚实。我知道当她说某件事好的时候，我会想：操，那确实太棒了。你知道的，比起那些消极的话，我真的更相信这个。这成了你真正的心情晴雨表。没错。
I can really trust her. So it's not so much, I mean, I tell her, obviously, because she's part of it, I have to like clear her tennis and golf schedule out here so that she can like, you know, pack up and move with me. But yeah, she likes a lot of stuff. She loves the long shots. She likes those kind of movies way more.
我真的可以信任她。所以倒不是说……我的意思是，我当然会告诉她，因为她也是其中的一部分，我得在这里腾出她的网球和高尔夫日程表，好让她能打包行李跟我一起搬走。但是的，她喜欢很多东西。她喜欢长镜头。她更喜欢那种类型的电影。
But she loved this movie, this fantasy movie, this school for good and evil. She really loved it. I can't wait to see it. She's a big golfer. She's a big golfer, we need to know. Let's double back to that. She's a big golfer and a really big tennis player.
但她真的很喜欢这部电影，这部奇幻电影，《善恶魔法学校》。她真的很喜欢。我迫不及待想看了。她是个狂热的高尔夫球手。她是个狂热的高尔夫球手，我们得了解一下。让我们回到这个话题。她是个狂热的高尔夫球手，而且是个非常厉害的网球运动员。
She's super athletic. She's gonna be 70 next year, but she plays with 30 year olds. I mean, she's ridiculous. She hikes every morning at 5 a.m., three miles every morning with six dogs. She takes my dogs and her dogs. Then she goes and she walks 18 holes,
她超级热爱运动。她明年就70岁了，但她跟30岁的人一起打球。我的意思是，她简直太离谱了。她每天早上5点去远足，每天早上带着六只狗走三英里（约4.8公里）。她带上我的狗和她的狗。然后她去打18个洞的高尔夫，
and then she plays tennis. No golf, no tennis for you? I only play golf with her, and usually just on Mother's Day, but I love tennis. But tennis is like a later sport that I just learned because I had to find something for cardio because I couldn't really run anymore.
接着再去打网球。那你呢，不打高尔夫也不打网球吗？我只跟她一起打高尔夫，而且通常只在母亲节那天，但我喜欢网球。不过网球是我最近才学会的一项运动，因为我得找点什么来做有氧运动，我真的不能再跑步了。
And so I found tennis and I was like, this is great cardio and I enjoy it. Tennis is great. What about the pickleball? We play a lot of golf. Jason and I play a lot of golf. No, not pickleball. No pickleball? No, I mean, isn't that like what old people play?
所以我发现了网球，然后我觉得：这作为有氧运动太棒了，而且我很享受。网球真的很棒。匹克球（美国方块球）呢？我们经常打高尔夫。杰森和我经常打高尔夫。不，不打匹克球。不打匹克球？不，我的意思是，那难道不是老年人玩的吗？
Yes, I think so. But it's sweeping the nation just because it's easy Americans really love to fucking Pickleball I I have played Sean's got a pickleball court and a toilet right in the middle of the court I'm up for pickleball. I would love to learn I played before I've played pickleball for it ruins your tennis game I don't advise it if you like tennis because you it engages the wrist too much. I like ping-pong I used to play paddle a lot. Anybody like ping-pong. Oh, I love ping-pong. I have a ping-pong table in my back I just bring up stuff that you don't have to move at all. Yeah
是的，我也这么觉得。但它正席卷全国，就因为很简单……美国人真的太他妈喜欢匹克球了……我……我玩过，肖恩有个匹克球场，球场正中间甚至还有个马桶。我很赞成打匹克球。我很乐意学。我以前玩过，我以前玩过匹克球……这会毁了你的网球技术。如果你喜欢网球，我不建议你玩，因为它对手腕的动用太多了。我喜欢乒乓球。我以前经常玩板球。有人喜欢乒乓球吗？哦，我超爱乒乓球。我后院就有一个乒乓球桌……我净挑那些根本不需要移动身体的项目。对。
Just my upper body Xbox. What about that? I play that I like watching TV now you You seem like such a brave person. What scares the hell out of you? What are you most afraid of? What's like his kryptonite? That's a great question. You do seem like a very brave person.
只需用到上半身。Xbox。那个呢？我玩那个，我喜欢看电视。你看起来是个如此勇敢的人。什么东西能把你吓得半死？你最害怕什么？什么是你的致命弱点？这真是个好问题。你确实看起来是一个非常勇敢的人。
Yeah, but an earned bravery, though. It's not fame. I kind of threw up in my mouth a little bit there. Yeah, spit it out. I mean, moving when you're 19, you can't speak English, you make a, like, yeah. I mean, a lot of that, when I think back, and now that I have kids, I'm like, you're 19, you can't speak English, you're making that like. I mean a lot of that when I think back and now that I have kids, I'm like that was just,
对，不过这是一种靠经历换来的勇敢。这不是什么名气。我刚才差点把晚饭都吐出来了。对，吐出来吧。我的意思是，19岁时背井离乡，不会说英语，你做出了一个……对。我的意思是，其中很多事，当我回想起来，而且现在我自己也有了孩子，我就会想：你当时19岁，不会说英语，你居然做出了那种……我的意思是，其中很多事，当我回想起来，而且现在我自己也有了孩子，我就会想：那简直是……
I feel like if I didn't come out of the circumstances that I did, no, my mom would have never done anything like that and I don't think I would have done anything like that but I came out of very complicated circumstances, I didn't really, there wasn't a lot of choice, it was like swim or drown, like what are you gonna do? Yeah, you're tough though, you seem very, you're very tough, this you can kind of see you have this kind of resolve this inner resolve that come For me anyway, I felt like it's always shone through and you seem I'm like, oh, yeah. Yeah, she's on top of her shit
我觉得如果不是因为我经历过那些复杂的环境，不，我妈妈绝对不会做那种事，我想我也不会做那种事。但我经历过非常复杂的环境，我真的没有太多选择，当时的情况就像是：要么游过去，要么淹死，你还能怎么办？不过你确实很坚强，你看起来非常……你真的很坚强，你可以看出你有一种这种决心，这种内在的决心……对我来说无论如何，我觉得它总是散发着光芒，而且我觉得：哦，是的。对，她把一切都处理得井井有条。
She's like the like don't talk to her. Yeah. What about like bees cuz like bees bees will turn me into Somebody I don't want to be seen. I think I've seen you like a scream like a girl What about bees? Because bees will turn me into somebody I don't want to be seen. I think I've seen you scream like a girl. I think I have, yeah. And I'll just run, I'll just disappear with a rocket flare like a cartoon character. Just, choom, I'll just leave.
她就像那种……别跟她废话的人。对。蜜蜂呢？因为蜜蜂会把我变成一个我不想让别人看到的人。我想我见过你像个小女孩一样尖叫。蜜蜂怎么样？因为蜜蜂会把我变成一个我不想让别人看到的人。我想我见过你像个小女孩一样尖叫。我想我确实尖叫过，对。而且我会直接逃跑，我会像卡通人物一样带着信号弹瞬间消失。就“咻”的一声，我直接就溜了。
I'll tell you, I saw a cockroach yesterday and I did not handle it well. Yeah, I'm not good with those guys either. I did not handle it well. I really could not, I didn't know what to do with it. I didn't want to kill it, but I also didn't want it to live. I was very, really torn. And then I just, the idea of stepping on it,
我跟你说，我昨天看到一只蟑螂，我当时处理得可真不怎么样。对，我也不太擅长对付那些家伙。我处理得确实不怎么样。我真的不知道该拿它怎么办。我不想弄死它，但我也绝不想让它活着。我当时内心非常纠结。然后我一想到要踩死它，
I couldn't, it was like. What did you do then? I made somebody else do it. Yeah, you called somebody in, and did you instruct them not to kill it? No, I was with a group of people. No, this one lady was really brave. She stepped on it, she took her shoe off and just did it.
我就做不到，感觉就像……那你当时怎么做的？我让别人去处理了。对，你叫了个人来，你有没有指示他们别弄死它？不，我当时跟一群人在一起。不，有个女士非常勇敢。她一脚踩上去，脱下鞋子就直接把它踩死了。
I was very grateful, yes. Is there anything within the realm and the bigger scope of what you do, so again, as an actor or a producer, a writer, director, whatever, is there anything that you can think of that you think, that seems scary for me to do? Would you dance or sing?
我当时太感激了，对。在你的工作领域和更大范畴内，也就是作为演员、制片人、编剧、导演等等，有没有什么事是你想想觉得：做那件事对我来说太可怕了？你会去跳舞或唱歌吗？
I would dance, I would love to dance. I don't think I would sing, I'm a terrible singer. Me too. Yeah, and I'm very uncomfortable singing. Like I break out in hives. That's why Jason Reitman always makes me sing in his movies because he just loves torturing me. But I don't know, I mean, listen,
我会跳舞，我很乐意跳舞。我觉得我不会唱歌，我是个糟糕的歌手。我也是。对，而且我对唱歌感到非常不自在。比如我一唱歌就会起荨麻疹。这就是为什么杰森·雷特曼总让我在他的电影里唱歌，因为他就是喜欢折磨我。不过我不知道，我的意思是，听着，
I was really worried, scared. I was scared of doing Megyn Kelly. I really, you know, it's one of those things where you're like hoping for the best, and you try and do as much work as possible, but there's no guarantee, right? And it's like, you're like four or five weeks in and you still don't sound like her, and I did the first round of prosthetics
我当时真的很担心、很害怕。我害怕演梅根·凯利。真的，你知道的，那是一种你只能祈祷一切顺利的事情，你尝试做了尽可能多的准备工作，但没有任何保证，对吧？而且就像，你拍了四五个星期了，听起来还是不像她，我做了第一轮特效化妆，
and I looked like Glenn Close. Like, it was weird. I don't know if this is gonna work out. And so you feel like, you kind of feel like you're out on a limb and you're sort of without a net. This can definitely go very wrong. I definitely felt that. How about when in Prometheus, when you just lit some guy up on fire.
我看起来像格伦·克洛斯。这就很怪异。我不知道这能不能行得通。所以你会觉得自己像是在走钢丝，而且没有任何安全网。这绝对会搞砸的。我当时确实有这种感觉。在《普罗米修斯》里，当你把某个家伙点燃的时候呢？
That was like, you had like a fire machine and the guy was standing. A flame thrower. Was it a fire machine, Sean? Or whatever it was called. I didn't really do that. Oh, you didn't? You had a fire gun. You had like a fire.
那就像……你当时拿着一台喷火器，然后那家伙站在那里。火焰喷射器。那是喷火机器吗，肖恩？还是不管它叫什么名字。我其实没真的干那事。哦，你没有？你当时拿着一把火枪。你拿着一把火枪……
You know, actually that one did light up, minus like there was nobody in front of me, but it did light up. I think they did one where it kind of lights up a little bit. And that was pretty bad. Oh, so that wasn't you just like blowing them to bits like that, lighting them on fire? No, they added that later. Oh, wow. I'm so sorry, Shirley.
你知道的，其实那个道具确实喷火了，只不过我前面没有人，但它确实喷火了。我想他们拍过一个镜头，就是那种稍微点着一点的。那还挺吓人的。哦，所以并不是你真的把他们炸成碎片，像这样把他们点着？不，那是他们后来特效加进去的。哦，哇。我很抱歉，查理兹。
Holy fucking shit. I love that movie so much. You do? That's so sweet. Oh my God. Welcome to Fan Fest, you know. I love that you go between Meg and Kelly in that. That's so sweet. Oh my God. Welcome to FanFest, you know. I love that you go between Meg and Kelly in that. That's so.
他妈的太棒了。我太喜欢那部电影了。真的吗？太可爱了。噢天哪。欢迎来到粉丝节，你知道的。我太喜欢你在梅根·凯利和那个角色之间无缝切换了。太可爱了。噢天哪。欢迎来到粉丝节，你知道的。我太喜欢你在梅根·凯利和那个角色之间无缝切换了。太……
I've seen Prometheus like 10 times. I love it. And you know it's wild. I mean that Maskbender is pretty amazing. I did a deep dive on YouTube about it because the engineer, I don't know, nevermind. These guys are gonna fall asleep and finish it. No, we wanna hear it so bad.
我把《普罗米修斯》看大约10遍了。我太爱它了。你知道这有多疯狂吗？迈克·法斯宾德的表现简直太惊艳了。我在YouTube上对它进行了深度研究，因为那个工程师，我不知道，算了。这几个家伙快要睡着了，赶紧结束吧。不，我们太想听了。
I wanna know what dying I've been driving on YouTube for. I don't know if this is true or not because Ridley Scott had, I don't know if it's true, but I heard that he had this original script that explained kind of the whole, they gave this engineer this dialogue that explained the whole movie, but he cut it, which was that in the Bible,
我很想知道我究竟在YouTube上看了什么好吗。我不知道这是真是假，因为雷德利·斯科特当时有……我不知道是不是真的，但我听说他有一个原始剧本，解释了整部电影，他们给这个工程师安排了一段台词，解释了整部电影，但他把它删掉了。那个台词是说，在《圣经》中，
when Jesus wasn't there for however many years, because you know the Bible cuts from when he was a kid to 30, that these engineers, these aliens came, picked him up, brought him to their planet, taught him how they should teach humanity, brought him back, and then that's what he tried to do, but they failed, and that's why these aliens want to come back and wipe it out, because it's gotten so bad. And you heard this where?
当耶稣有那么多年不知去向时——因为你知道《圣经》里直接跳过了他小时候到30岁的这段经历——其实是这些工程师、这些外星人来接走他，把他带到他们的星球，教导他应该如何教育全人类，然后再把他送回来，然后他就是这么去做的，但他们失败了，这就是为什么这些外星人想要回来把人类全部消灭，因为人类已经变得太糟糕了。你从哪儿听到这个的？
Online somewhere. Wow. I can't verify that for you, that's really interesting. It's fascinating, isn't it? And if it's not true, it's a good idea. It's a great. It's fascinating isn't it fuck and if it's not true It's a good idea. It's a great idea world is round to Sean. It's it's round It's where but anyway, I think some some some listeners right now are Touching themselves like yeah people really appreciate that kind of knowledge
网上的某个地方。哇。我可没法为你证实真伪，这真的很有趣。这不是很迷人吗？就算这不是真的，这也是个好主意。这真是一个……这不是很迷人吗，操，就算这不是真的，这也是个好主意。这真是一个伟大的主意……地球是圆的，肖恩。它是圆的。这地方……不过不管怎样，我觉得现在有些听众可能在
Like am I fucking Is this actually did I just pass out? What am I did I feel? I didn't know if you knew if you heard that if that was true No, you know why cuz she doesn't spend her time on reddit with you and Scottie Fucking putting in Prometheus fucking theories Scotty we should get to bed. It's 4 a.m. No, but look at this thread I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this?
自我安慰呢，就像：是的，人们真的很欣赏这种知识。就像：我他妈的……这到底是真是假？我是不是刚昏过去？我到底在……我刚才感觉……我不知道你知不知道，你有没有听说过那是真的？不，你知道为什么吗？因为她才不会像你和斯科蒂一样把时间浪费在红迪网（Reddit）上，
I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this?
去发那些他妈的《普罗米修斯》理论……斯科蒂，我们该睡觉了。现在都凌晨4点了。不，但是你看这个帖子，我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？
我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？
I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I'm like, what the fuck is this? I You guys, I really love this show. Congratulations. I listen to it all the time when I'm stuck waiting to pick my kids up. It's a joy to listen to you guys.
我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？我在想：这他妈到底是什么鬼？伙计们，我真的很喜欢这个节目。祝贺你们。我每次被困在路边等接孩子时都会听。听你们聊天真是一种享受。
You're really funny. Thank you. Thanks for trying. And thank you for having me. I guess you ran out of people. Yeah, I do. Every time I would listen to it, I thought, yeah, spirit, how between Jason and Will,
你们真的太搞笑了。谢谢。谢谢你们的夸奖。也谢谢你们邀请我来。我猜你们是找不到别人了吧。对，确实是。每次我听这个节目的时候，我都在想，天哪，在杰森和威尔之间，
between both of you, I couldn't make. It's Will, but that's. Will, that's how we say it in African. I was like, wow, I'm like, you guys must have really cleared your list. Even you, Sean, I know you too. What the fuck happened? Can I tell you something? What is it, season 17?
你们俩之间，我怎么就……这是威尔，不过……威尔，我们在非洲就是这么念的。我当时就想：哇，我觉得你们俩的嘉宾名单肯定早就清空了。甚至连你，肖恩，我也知道你们俩……这他妈到底怎么回事？我能告诉你一件事吗？现在是第17季吗？
No, can I tell you something right now? You've been on my list since day one, and obviously, Jason, you were on Jason's list as well. Yeah, and I was like, no, I get her. So, Will is the one that we villainize. No, no, no, I had a different list and then it just, I don't know. I didn't have a pen. I didn't end up having a pen.
不，我能现在告诉你一件事吗？你从第一天起就在我的名单上，而且很显然，杰森，你也一直在杰森的名单上。对，然后我想：不，我懂她。所以，威尔才是那个被我们当作反派的人。不，不，不，我有另外一份名单，然后……我不知道。我当时没带笔。我最后甚至没找到笔。
Well, thank you for having me, you guys. We love you. Have a great rest of the day. Love you right back. You guys, too. Thank you for doing this. All right. Bye. Bye. Bye. That right. Bye. Bye. Bye. That was so funny.
好吧，谢谢你们邀请我来，伙计们。我们爱你。祝你们今天剩下的时间过得愉快。我也爱你们。你们也是。谢谢你们抽出时间做这个。好了。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。太搞笑了。
I love that, what is that theory for Prometheus? Is that really what it was about? Well, I mean, if there's this one guy's thing, he said he had a copy of the script and like that the whole point of the aliens wanting to wipe out Earth is because we're not getting it right, we're making the Earth worse.
我太喜欢了，关于《普罗米修斯》的那个理论到底是什么？那真的是电影想表达的吗？嗯，我的意思是，如果按某个人的一套说法，他说他有一份剧本复印件，上面写着外星人想要消灭地球的全部意义在于，我们没有把事情做好，我们正在把地球搞得更糟。
Why do you encourage me to tell it again? He's just repeating what he already said. I'm just fascinated that you just like go in and look for meanings. Like when you saw Charlie and the Chocolate Factory, did you do a deep dive for the meaning of that? Yeah, that's pretty much straightforward. That's just from the books.
你为什么还要鼓励我再讲一遍？他只是在重复他刚才已经说过的话。我只是觉得很着迷，你竟然会去深入挖掘并寻找各种寓意。就像你看《查理和巧克力工厂》的时候，你也会对它的寓意进行深度研究吗？对，那部电影基本上非常直白。那就是根据原著书本来拍的。
That's one of my favorite movies. Charlie and the Chocolate Factory? The original. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, I love that movie too. Great get. Now that was just great to have our buddy Charlize on. How do you know her, Jason?
那是我最喜欢的电影之一。《查理和巧克力工厂》？原版。对，对，对，对。对，我也很喜欢那部电影。请到好嘉宾了。能请到我们的好朋友查理兹来做客真是太棒了。你是怎么认识她的，杰森？
I didn't know you knew her so well. Just from Arrested. In a movie, can you guys make a movie together? Oh, that's right, and we also did, wait, did I do Hancock before or after Arrested? After. After, yeah. After.
我不知道你跟她这么熟。就从《发展受阻》开始。在电影里，你们能一起拍部电影吗？哦，对的，我们还拍过——等等，我拍《全民超人汉考克》是在《发展受阻》之前还是之后？之后。之后，对。之后。
Yeah, that was really, really fun. That was my first, maybe only, big budget movie. That was pretty impressive seeing that whole big superhero engine. Yeah, that was a huge movie that you did. But yeah, she came and did five episodes of Arrested Velvet, something like that. The most Canadian pronunciation of five.
对，那真的非常有意思。那是我的第一部，也可能是唯一一部大预算电影。看到整个庞大的超级英雄制作机器，真的挺震撼的。对，那是你拍的一部大制作电影。不过对，她来客串了五集《发展受阻》，差不多吧。这是对“五”字最加拿大式的发音。
I ran into her at the airport when she was nominated for Monster. She was making the rounds, and I was doing press too, and there was this room. What were you doing press for, Sean? Will and Grace or something. And we'd just done Oprah, like the same day, and I saw her at the airport,
我曾在机场偶遇她，当时她正因《女魔头》获得提名。她到处跑通告，我也在做宣传，然后有个房间。肖恩，你当时在为什么做宣传？《威尔和格蕾丝》还是什么的。我们那天刚上过奥普拉的节目，就在同一天，我在机场看到她，
and I did this big dance for her, and she looked at me like I... At the airport you did? Yeah, just trying to make her laugh and she was like what's wrong with you like did you have time to get into it land did you have time to get into what was wrong with you no no if you were if you were late for a flight you must not have had time to get to answer that right what's wrong with you remember she had so she did the show and we had also had,
我为她跳了一支大舞，而她看着我的眼神就像我……你在机场跳的？对，就想逗她笑，而她的表情就像是“你怎么了”。你当时有时间跟她深入交流吗？你有时间解释你怎么了吗？没有，没有，如果你赶不上航班，你肯定没时间回答那个问题对吧？“你怎么了？”记不记得她不仅演了这档节目，而且我们还……
remember we had Patty Jenkins the year before who directed Monster, directed Arrested. She was awesome. Wait, Patty Jenkins directed Arrested at the moment too? Yeah, who went on to do the Wonder Woman films and etc. Who's amazing. You guys had great directors. What's the name of the show?
记不记得前一年我们有派蒂·杰金斯，她执导了《女魔头》，还执导了《发展受阻》。她太棒了。等等，派蒂·杰金斯当时也执导了《发展受阻》？对，她后来去执导了《神奇女侠》等电影。她太厉害了。你们有很棒的导演。这节目叫什么名字？
Oh my god, it's so... Should we come over? We should come over. We'll walk over to Sean's house. We'll watch some of the rest of development and then you come over to one of our houses. We'll watch Will and Grace together. We'll watch Will and Grace. That sounds like a fun... We'll make a new podcast out of it. Yeah. You know a little watch through. We'll sign a contract that we each we're all gonna watch watch it in. That contract will be binding. You guys, I fucking I was crying, laughing so hard. Good God. Smart.
天哪，这太……我们要不要过去？我们应该过去。我们散步去肖恩家。我们看一会儿剩下的《发展受阻》，然后你们去我们其中一个人的家里。我们一起看《威尔和格蕾丝》。我们看《威尔和格蕾丝》。听起来挺有意思的……我们用它做个新播客吧。对。你知道的，一起重温一下。我们签个合同，规定我们每个人、我们所有人都要看。那个合同将具有法律约束力。伙计们，我特么笑得眼泪都快出来了。天哪。聪明。
Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf and Bennett Barbeco. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。《SmartLess》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔贝科100%有机且手工打造。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。